Hello, hello everybody!
Yes, I am very echo-y.
Holy shit, I'm so echo-y.
It's not like there's nothing here.
There's so many stuff in my room right now.
Okay, it's cause it's- yes, this is my very first stream at my new apartment.
So like, I don't know what to do.
It's echo-y.
I'm a mess right now.
To be fair, I've been a mess for a while.
Oh my gosh, I finally set up my entire, like, desk and PC and everything.
So like, yes, there's no windows in here, but there is a glass door.
It's like a glass sliding door.
And, oh my god, you're right, I should- What will happen if I just, like, pour all the plushies out?
And- Sorry!
I found out- Why- I don't fucking know why I ran.
So, I found out I have, like, five plus boxes of just plushies that I've collected over seven years.
So, like, I was like, I'm gonna just grab a bunch of plushies and I just pour everything out.
And, like, they're not, like, small boxes, too.
They're, like, those- the biggest moving boxes you can have.
So, like, cause, like, there was, like, some tape boxes that was, like, seven plus years old.
And I was like, what the fuck are these?
And then I, like, pick it up.
It's, like, super light and I open it.
It's, like, it's, like, there's, like, five plus boxes of just plushies.
So- Oh, everything feels so weird.
Ah, I hate it!
Okay, so, like, you know, like, um, I really hate it when, um- Also, like, if Sound Guy is here- Sound Guy, I need you to double check if there's any crackling or anything.
Because I- I- I bought, like, a hundred plus dollars worth of cable management stuff because I had no- I've never had cable management before.
So I bought, like- I bought, like, wire holders.
I bought, like, those Velcro things.
I bought, like, wire- like, cable sleeve holders.
And then I bought, like, uh- I bought two Velcro holders.
And- I
- And then I bought, like, cable labels.
Like, Velcro labels.
So I- Like, color-coded Velcro labels.
I've never- I've never had cable management before.
And I was, like, okay.
Now that I am doing the- the- the desk stuff, I guess I shall invest on a hundred dollars worth of cable management stuff.
Um- So- And then- Um- Yes, I have reverb because I just moved.
And- And I just fully moved.
Um- And, like- It's not like this is an empty- That's the worst part.
It's not like this is, like, an empty- It's okay, it's Canadian money.
A hundred dollars worth of Canadian money.
So, like, that's, like, fifty dollars for you.
So- Hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor hor.
JT, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Does the hor hor travel in the echo?
Okay, so, like- I don't know.
Should I just grab a box of plushies and just- Like- Just- Just, like- Uh- Just chuck it on the floor?
Like, would that help?
Would that- Wait- Would that actually help?
I don't know.
I've never done- Oh my god.
Everything feels so weird.
Because I hate it when, like- Um- I hate it when- Uh- When- Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna grab a box of plushies and then just- Just throw it on the floor.
And then just see what happens.
Um- Put them in the corner?
In the corner?
But where will I walk?
Where will I- I don't even put them in corners?
Like, I can only put in two corners.
Okay.
Um- Because like, everything feels off.
You know?
Like, how the monitors feel off and everything.
And I'm like- How do I- How do I look at my second monitor?
I have a mic stand right here.
How did I do that?
I'm just like- Oh my god.
My mic stand is like- Here.
How was I able to look at- How was I able to- How was I able to like- Look at my second monitor?
I- I don't know.
I can't- Alright.
Guys, I'm gonna grab my box of plushies.
I'm just gonna chuck it on the floor.
I'll be right back, guys.
Guys, we're doing it all live.
Alright, you can hear my sliding door.
My sliding glass door.
See, guys?
Can you still hear me?
I'm grabbing my plushies.
Box of plushies.
I found it, everybody.
I found it.
We traveled.
It was in my room.
I found box number one.
And they're all like, in garbage bags.
Okay.
Gonna chuck some plushies in the corner.
I just hope that doesn't get in here.
Did the acoustic- Did it help?
Did it- Oh my god.
Packing this up is gonna be a pain.
I don't want- Oh.
I don't wanna pick this up.
Oh.
I got it.
Did it help?
Did it actually help?
I can't tell.
Did it actually absorb it?
Oh my god.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
All right.
I have it on my back corner.
But how much?
Do I put more?
Wait, it actually did?
My plushies actually absorbed it?
I'm going to put it on the other corner.
All right.
God, I don't want to fucking clean this.
I can grab more.
All right.
Is it better?
Should I bring more plushies?
Guys, hold it like a whopping five or six.
Wait, does it actually?
Wait, I was looking around.
Wait, it's actually better.
My noise-canceling plushies.
Okay.
I have it in two corners.
I can put it on the third corner, but I can't put it on the fourth corner because the fourth corner is where all my PC stuff is.
So, like, I'm going to bring it back.
I'm bringing the third.
I'm bringing two more garbage bags of plushies.
I'll be right back.
I need to make sure dad doesn't get in here.
I'm back.
I'm back with more plushies.
Okay, I'm going to stuff this corner with more plushies.
I'm going to stuff this corner.
Okay.
All right.
Ooh, that's a lot of plushies.
My god, it's like Pokemon and, like, Baymax.
Okay.
There it is.
I'm going to take a picture of this.
I'll take a picture of this right now, actually.
Just let you see, like, the corner of plushies.
Then one giant Snorlax plushie gets to have this one corner all by himself.
All right.
The adventures.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
I'll take a picture, too.
Okay.
I am not looking forward to cleaning this right after.
All right.
I'm not going to be moving because I...
You can see a picture of dad just looking at it and being like, I don't want to do it.
Okay.
Just looking at it.
All right.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm making sure there's no reflection of anything.
All right.
Let me send this to myself.
By the way, I just realized why you guys were right.
I should not put my PC in a room with no windows.
I need a bike.
I need to buy an air conditioner in here.
I need to buy a portable air conditioner.
Oh, God, it's so hot in here.
It's so hot.
Okay.
All right.
Let me show you what I did.
Let's see.
All right.
Is it better?
I can't tell.
I legitimately can't tell if it's better or not.
Alright, here we go.
This is...
This is what it looks like.
So, in this corner, I have a...
I have a...
Dad's just looking in.
Dad's just...
I have a bunch of plushies in the corner.
Let him...
No!
He's gonna fucking rip it apart!
What do you mean?
So...
I should buy those foam soundproof things.
I've never had to buy one of those before.
But I feel like I'll need them.
He looks so confused.
He's like, let me in!
Let me in!
But yes, here we go.
Now, you see...
You see...
Dad in the corner looking in and being like...
What the fuck?
Let me in!
So, did it help?
Did it help the echo?
Did it help?
I am not looking forward to cleaning all of this up later.
Why do you have a Wii U?
Because I've been unpacking!
Okay, funny story.
Funny story, but...
So...
I had my last move.
For my PC stuff.
By the way, I'm so glad I moved because I hated that place I used to live.
Like...
I hated that place because the elevators were always broken.
And there was not a lot of elevators.
There were not a lot of elevators.
I'm using plushies as soundproof right now.
And...
Because of that, the elevators were always broken.
And usually, only one elevator would work.
And I fucking hated that place!
So I'm glad.
I'm glad it's gone.
I don't live there anymore.
Anyway, so, funny story.
I recently had my final move.
A final move.
I won't say what day it was.
But like, I didn't pay for professional movers this time because I was like, okay, for the second time, I don't think I really need professional movers because I'm pretty sure I don't have a lot of stuff left.
And, um...
So I was like, oh, okay.
I'm going to...
I don't have any, like, guy friends that live in my city.
So I was asking around, like, mutual friends and stuff.
Being like, oh, do you guys have mutual friends that live here?
And then, there was one.
There was one guy friend.
Mutual guy friend.
I don't know who they are.
I literally met them for the move.
And it was so fun because...
So, they don't know what I do.
They do not know what I do.
And, um...
My friend told this guy, they're like, oh, don't worry.
It'll be very simple.
You just need to move, like, you just need to move, like, a desk and a chair.
And they're like, oh, okay.
Yeah.
Like, I'm down for it.
If it's just, like, a chair and a table, then that's fine.
Little does he know, it was not just a chair or a table.
We had to do two trips.
We had...
The thing is, okay, the funny thing is that the mutual friend, not mutual, not my mutual, but, like, the friend of the friend, they were, like, a dad.
So, they're, like, much older because he has, like, five children.
Five kids.
So, like, my friend was like, oh, don't worry.
Like, he has a really big car.
He has a huge van because he has five kids.
So, like, the van's gonna fit, like, everything.
And I was like, oh, that's sweet.
Yeah.
That's good to know.
And...
So, so, like, uh...
So, like, still, two trips, by the way.
It's still...
It's still requiring two trips.
Anyway, he felt really scammed because, apparently, he had to go to work at five in the morning the next day.
He had to go to...
He had to... He was like...
He, like, texted my friend because my friend was like, what the fuck happened?
I was like, oh, yeah, it was not just a desk and a chair, but... I was like, sorry.
It was not just a desk and a chair.
Because... Because...
Um... By the way, I felt really bad.
I didn't pay him because I was like... I felt really bad because, like, we had to do two trips and he had to carry everything.
He basically carried the majority of the stuff for me.
And...
And I was like...
And I was like, I'm so sorry.
I could pay you a bit.
I could give you some money for, like...
Basically carrying everything.
Like, from the desk, the boxes, and... and, like, the chair.
And so...
Okay, and then...
Okay, this is so embarrassing.
So he was like, oh, what do you do?
Like, oh, what do you do?
Oh, my gosh, you need, like, three monitors.
What do you do?
And I was like, oh, um...
Um, yeah, I, like...
It's NDA.
I can't really say what I do because it's, like, I signed, like, a contract.
So, like, it's sort of NDA and, uh...
And, like, for...
privacy sake, you know?
And then... So he was like...
And then... But he was like, oh, but, like, do you make a lot?
It seems like you make a lot to, like, live in such a nice place.
And then I was like, yeah, I make a lot of money.
And then he was like, are you an OnlyFans?
I was like, no.
No.
It's not OnlyFans.
I was like, no, it's not OnlyFans.
But it's not OnlyFans.
Oh my god.
Um...
Yeah, so, like, he knows that it's not OnlyFans.
And, like, honestly, that's all that matters.
That's all that matters.
But...
Um...
But, yeah, I like my new place a lot.
I just need to, um, you know, redecorate it a lot.
Especially, like, the streaming room, the office room.
Um...
Because, like I said, it's, like, super echoey right now.
The reverb and everything.
And, uh, definitely, I cannot use plushies as my, as my like, what's it called?
I cannot, guys, I cannot use plushies to absorb the sound, guys.
I hate it.
We need, like, actual, like, soundproof foam.
Um...
But, yeah, like I said, I really hate, I really hate, uh, um...
When, like, I have to, like, figure out, like, if my monitors are positioned correctly and everything.
Uh, because, like, I'm not used to I don't know.
It feels off.
It just, everything feels off.
I just need to get used to it.
I can't fix it.
I just need to...
I just need to figure it out.
I need to figure it out.
Um, but yes, I'm glad to be...
Do I need to get another, another garbage bag of plushies?
I have one more.
I mean, this all came from one box.
I still have four more boxes, but I got fine.
Figure out where the four boxes are.
But should I grab one more, one more, one more bag of plushies and throw it in the corner?
I don't know which corner.
Which corner do I throw it?
Yeah, we, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna grab, I'll grab the last one.
I'll grab the last trash bag of plushies.
I'll be right back.
I don't know where the other box is!
There's so many boxes!
There's so many boxes.
I don't know what to do.
I'm coming back.
Dad thinks the plushies are for him.
Jokes on him.
They're not.
Okay.
You go in this corner.
And I guess I'll chuck them here.
Alright.
Four plushies on the corner.
There we go.
That was an entire box of, an entire box of plushies.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
I don't want to clean this up.
I don't want to clean.
Alright.
Anyway, I'm happy to be back.
Um...
Definitely feel like I need to adjust a lot of stuff right now.
Um, but yes!
I am currently streaming for the first time at my new place!
Yeah!
Before then, I had to do a commute back and forth because um, like I said, uh, I was not expecting...
Like, I didn't realize I had internet already in place.
I thought to install it, but it was, like, ready like, right away.
So, like, and I was like, oh, well, it's too late.
I still have to do the commute back and forth, so...
So, uh, I finally managed to plug everything in.
Um, everything is all plugged and everything is all working.
I think.
I hope so.
So, we're good for...
I didn't know what to play.
Like...
Yesterday, I was so tired.
I didn't... I...
It was funny because I made the...
Because I do have my laptop.
So, like, I made the waiting room on my laptop, but had nothing set up.
Like, I literally had, like, none of my stuff is plugged in.
None of the cables are... Like, everything was... All the cables were in a box.
I put the waiting room up and I used that as, like, motivation to set everything up.
I was like, okay.
Okay.
I'm gonna have to...
I have a time.
I need to have everything set up by the time it's time to start stream.
Because it was, like, the only way to motivate me.
To actually put everything together before the starting stream time.
Because yesterday...
I was supposed to do it yesterday, but I fell asleep.
And I was supposed to do it... Yeah, I was supposed to do it yesterday and the day before yesterday.
Wait, no.
Yeah, yesterday and the day before yesterday, but I fell asleep.
So...
I kept...
I kept sleeping instead.
I was just very EP, okay?
I was just very EP.
Um, so I had to do the waiting room as, like, my final resort to, like, actually set everything up for everything.
Oh, my God.
I'm such a mess, everybody.
Anyway, Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you have any towel racks and blankets?
Um, things you put on walls of your room?
It doesn't have to be professional soundproofing.
If you're just looking to dab... Wait, if I put...
posters, does it dampen the sound?
Guys?
Does it do that?
Does that... Because, like, I could... Instead of putting, like, foam, I can, like, put the soundproof foam.
I can just...
I can just put posters?
Does that work like that?
It does help?
No?
Okay, not much.
Okay, because, like, I'm, like, thinking, do I put posters or... Do I put posters or, like, the foam?
Technically.
Just... Okay, I'll put the foam.
Because I was like, do I put posters or foam?
Like, in front of me.
You know?
Like, in front of me at the moment.
But then you guys are like, it doesn't really help that much.
Okay, I'll get foam.
I don't want it to look like a streamer room.
Like, you know, like, like the gaming room with, like, foam everywhere.
Like, foam in front of me.
It looks so ugly.
It's so ugly, though.
I don't want it.
I don't want it to look like a streamer room.
But you are... Yeah, but, like, I want it to be, like, aesthetic.
I just want it to be, like, a mini shrine room dedicated to me, you know?
There's thick curtains.
There's no windows.
What do you mean, thick curtains?
There's no... It's literally four walls.
Okay, one, two, three, four.
Sorry, I have to make sure there's four.
It's literally four walls of nothing.
It's literally four walls.
I have no windows.
That's true.
There's the glass door.
Anyway, guys, I thought it was so smart.
I was like, oh, man, I don't want to live in a green house because that's my problem with my old apartment.
It was like...
I had to make sure it was four, okay?
I had to make sure.
The thing is, my old apartment was a fucking green house.
But then I didn't realize.
I didn't realize the air conditioning fucking sucks in this room.
And I don't want to...
Oh, I need acoustic panels.
Okay.
Okay, sound guy, I need you to like...
Wait, can I put posters on the phone?
Would it look cool?
Would it look good, though?
Posters on the phone?
Oh, shit.
Thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It's like, I didn't want the sun to shine in.
But then, like, I can't... I can't turn up the air conditioning too much because I don't want to fucking freeze Dad.
I don't want to freeze him.
I don't want...
I don't want to open my glass door because, like, because then Dad's going to come in here, rip out, and take away my acoustic plushies.
Like, I need the plushies for...
I need the plushies for...
for the cats without the sound.
He's going to kidnap them if I...
if I open the door.
Get Dad a sweater.
Okay.
We're definitely going to need to buy a sweater for him because I'm going to be turning up the AC later.
Next time.
Because it's...
It's... I realize...
I realize we might not...
We might not have...
Like, um...
We might not, like, have the sun anymore.
But, like, my PC is still producing a lot of hot air.
.
Johnny, look good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Interior dog fence fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
So, today, we are going to be playing Into the Pit.
Oh, also, like, I managed to... I... Hell no.
I don't know.
I don't know why you would watch me, but, like, um, Lazy Madman gave me an invite code for... Was it that new Riot fighting game?
2XKO or whatever?
So, I do have a... I do have, like, an invite to the... the Riot fighting game.
But, like, I...
I don't know how to fucking play fighting games, so...
Oh, sorry.
2K...
Guys!
I have... I don't know fighting games!
But, yeah, Lazy...
Lazy Madman gave me an invite to it yesterday.
So, like, this week, we're gonna... I guess... I mean, it's Alpha.
So, like, this week, we're gonna check it out, I guess, and get absolutely destroyed.
So... So, we're gonna...
We're gonna try that out, like, this week.
And then, other than that, I think this week's schedule is, like, God of War, 2XKO, and then a member stream.
Because we don't really have a lot of days.
You know what I'm super excited about?
Next week is gonna be, uh, Wukong.
Um, Wukong's coming out next week, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Wukong's coming out next week, and I'm super-duper excited.
Uh, for that.
We're gonna start Wukong.
I think we're gonna do Wukong on on launch day.
Like, launch hour launch day.
So, like, I'm super excited about that game.
Because that game looks really, really good.
I mean, like, it'll... I hope.
I hope so!
I really hope so!
Anyway!
Um, happy 10-year anniversary for FNAF!
Um, this is one of the many games they released for, uh, to celebrate 10 years.
I can't believe it.
10 years of Five Nights at Freddy's.
Um, and apparently this game is really good in the series.
Even though, like, it's not...
it's not... it's different from the actual...
it's different from the, um, the other games.
But people are saying it's really, really good.
And, um, they have a VTuber reference in there.
There's a VTuber reference in there, which I thought was...
which I thought was pretty funny.
I saw, like, a screenshot of it.
I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, yeah, they added... they added V... they added, like, a VTuber fan in the game.
Alright, Sound Guy, let me know how the sound is like.
Let me know if it's okay.
Ooh!
Wow!
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, sorry.
And you're like...
I'm like, I don't even know if, like, everything's okay right now.
I feel... I just feel a little off.
Just a little bit.
Alright, this game has an autosave feature.
I love autosave features.
I love that.
Whoa!
I need to turn it down for myself.
Alright, Mega Cat Studios.
Apparently, they made FNAF Mario Kart, but, like, it's not...
It's, like, buggy as hell.
Press any key...
Alright.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, settings...
So, yeah, this game recently came out.
And I was like, fuck it.
I don't wanna lose FOMO.
And apparently it's, um...
It's not that long, which enables... You know what?
Fuck it, let's go.
Fuck it, let's do this.
Alright, font size...
Ooh!
What the fuck?
That's huge!
Okay.
Hint rate...
Five minutes.
Okay, wait.
Alright, ten minutes.
Okay, ten minutes is good.
Okay, hiding minigames...
Default?
What is it?
Autoplay?
Okay, default, run mode...
Uh... There's streamer mode?
What's... Which one is streamer mode?
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
I actually have, like, no idea what this game is about.
Apparently... I was looking up, like, I was trying to, like, um... Before I was, like, Oh, maybe I should make my own thumbnail.
Because I figured... I was, like, trying to debate on what to play.
Because I was, like, okay, what's a good one-off today?
Because, like, I didn't want to play, like, a series.
And then I was, like, what's a good one-off?
And then I was, like, alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna do this as a one-off.
Um, and... But the thing is, like, I decided that at, like, 9 a.m.
And I told my...
I didn't know my thumbnail maker is, like, awake.
And I felt really bad.
Because I was, like, hey, can you make a thumbnail within, like, one to two hours?
Because I don't even know you're awake right now.
I don't think this... I was trying to make my own...
I was trying to make my own thumbnail.
And, like, I found out it was based off a book or something.
It was, like, a fan game.
And then Scott was, like, mine.
So...
Um...
So, um... Now it's...
Is it canon?
I don't know.
I have no idea if this is canon or not.
But people said it's really good.
So, we'll see.
I mean, I actually have, like, no idea what the actual story of FNAF is.
So...
Uh, this is gonna be interesting.
Oh, it's canon now?
That's sweet.
Alright.
Uh...
Yes.
You can barely see the center.
Alright, that means...
It won't be scary if I...
I imagine I played it like that.
Okay.
Alright, we'll do middle.
Middle seems good.
Alright.
Confirm.
Creepy, frightening, a balanced...
A narrative experience?
A balance experience?
Wait, what's normal?
Okay, I guess...
Frightening?
Is this easy?
Is this... I don't need...
Fucking random names, like...
I...
Please, just make it easy, medium, hard.
Like, I can't...
What the fuck does creepy mean?
What does...
What does creepy mean?
What does frightening mean?
Just give me easy, mean, normal, hard.
Creepy... Okay.
They're both scary.
Like, they both mean the same thing.
Um...
Creepy means super okay.
Frightening.
Alright.
Yes.
Alright, we're gonna go with that.
Creepy equals evil.
I'm so sad I didn't get to go to artist...
I didn't get to walk around...
Get taken around Artist Alley for my two conventions last week.
I was so busy.
I was really upset about that.
Not upset, but I'm just sad I couldn't do it.
Just because of how busy I was.
Oh no, it's time to read.
Oswald!
It's time to go!
My god!
Why is he drawing animatronics?
You know what this style reminds me of?
Like the Rick and Morty pixel art.
Pocket Mortys!
Yes!
That's what it reminds me of.
Pocket Mortys.
Isn't there anywhere else I can go?
The pizza was good the first couple of times.
But I really want to do something new.
Aw, come on, Oz.
Wait, is my dad single?
Is he divorced?
Where's mom?
Aw, come on, Oz.
Jeff's can't be the worst place to hang out.
Every day has been the same all summer long.
I go in, get pizza, stare at the grease stained yellow walls stare at the grease stained yellow walls Where's mom?
Didn't wait for you to pick me up.
Where's the fun in that?
I'm almost glad school's starting tomorrow.
Just so I can only have to see that place on the weekends now.
I'm sorry, son.
I know no kids only option for fun should be hanging around a rundown pizza joint.
But Jeff is all we got.
It's all we can afford.
Just leave him at home.
What's wrong with leaving the child at home?
Am I allowed to say that?
I was left at home alone a lot.
Is that illegal?
Wait, is that illegal?
I was not left home alone, guys.
Guys!
I lied.
I was not.
I was not left home alone.
You know, money's been tight since the mill closed.
Once I'm a full time at the corner store...
If the corner store...
Hypothetically, I might have been left alone a lot at home.
If the corner store even survives that long, everything in this town is dead or dying.
And there's no telling what's closing next.
...
Why can't we go to the next town over where everyone else is moving?
All my friends are there now.
It can't be that hard for grandma to travel a few miles.
Well...
Unless her frail bones overnight.
Moving is a no-go.
Put her in a home.
Wait, that's fucked.
Sorry.
Can we just pack grandma up in some bubble wrap?
Huh.
If only they were that easy.
Even with the mighty strength of bubble wrap, she...
Oh, they can cause they're poor.
I fucking forgot about that.
She's still too fragile.
And that's not going to change.
Fucking grandma.
Speaking of things not changing, I bet that possum is still on the corner at the stoplight.
Oh yeah?
Let's make a deal.
If that critter's still there, I'll give you an extra buck for another slice of Jeff's.
Wait, it's called Jeff's instead of Five Nights at Freddy's?
What kind of fucking, like, pizza joint is just called Jeff?
Easy money?
Oh!
Still... that's fucked.
What the fu- Still dead.
Why the fuck would you show your kid that?
Bro!
What?
Things will get better, Oz.
It's like...
What kind of dad am I if I can't make him happy?
Let alone afford to feed him more than pizza.
But kids love pizza, Dad!
I had pizza yesterday.
I'm sorry things turned out this way, Oswald.
I think it's YouTube.
Cause my internet's fine.
Well...
Yeah, Dad.
Remember when this was the place to be?
Totally.
My parents took me here all the time.
I still remember playing in the ball pit and getting- What?
And getting ring- When is this?
When is this?
That's a health code violation.
And a ringworm.
Ew.
Probably why it's still roped up.
That and well...
You know...
Hmm...
Secret ball pit?
Huh?
Oh yeah, never touch ball pits.
They never clean it.
What I've heard is that it doesn't matter what kind of ball pit, but they never clean the ball pits cause there's no point.
They're like really nasty and everything.
Oh my god!
There's my secret tablet!
I'm here!
Free refills.
For what?
I only wish it was orange juice.
Hey!
Speed runs start now!
Hey kid.
You want another slice of cheese and a refill on that orange juice?
Not right now.
Just checking around.
Well, have fun.
Not much to look at other than dust bunnies and cobwebs.
I don't think they bite.
Dust bunnies?
No.
The wolf spiders.
Okay!
This has to be the 80s!
Like there's... what are the help code... what are all these help code violations?
Oh.
Good luck then.
Alright.
The door is locked?
How's the door locked?
Isn't this the entrance?
To the pizza joint?
This has to be.
This is like the time where you can break as many help codes as you want.
They don't even have any good flavors there.
I promise that I stay here until I come to get them.
Okay.
We gotta find the ball pit.
You can never leave!
Ooh.
I mean extra protein though.
The wolf spiders in your pizza?
You got some extra proteins.
Okay.
Employees?
It has to be here, right?
The door is locked.
Oh.
Can I...
Let's not talk about that disgusting ball pit anymore.
Pre-dashed.
Con.
It's employed.
Can I go through there?
Okay.
No.
Well, I mean it's 2D so like there's not much area to go.
Whoa.
Hey!
It does exist!
It looks kinda gross.
But I wonder what Dad would do if I hid and went missing for a while.
Maybe teach him a lesson not to leave me at such a creepy place all day.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh.
Bring down the music a little bit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Wait.
Does it stop by What are you trying?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh no guys.
I am I'm losing time!
I didn't bring down the music!
Okay.
Bring down the music and then overall Okay.
Oh no guys.
I'm losing time on my speed run.
Alright.
Here's hoping I don't get pink eye.
Like kids pee and poop everywhere.
Oh God.
Wait.
What?
What the?
Wait.
What?
Is this a time travel ball pit?
It's like hot tub hot tub time machine?
Ball pit time machine?
What?
Where am I?
Children!
Is this the bite of 55?
Dad says we're gonna go to the movies later!
No!
It's the bite of 25!
Yes!
You know I watched it.
I watched that in 3 years.
I was way too young to be watching that!
What are you saying?
No!
It's 82 right?
Oh!
It's the bite of 82!
I don't know.
Something about people busting ghosts.
Can't remember the title.
1825 Oh!
I saw that one last week!
Don't get slimed!
These characters look like the ones I draw!
Wait!
Am I purple guy?
Did I?
This place is the best!
I wanna stay here forever!
Bite of 9-1-1 Bite of 9-1-1 Let's eat!
Let's go!
A brown bear, a blue rabbit, and some kind of bird girl!
Creepy!
But everyone seems to like them!
I mean they are not creepy yet!
Okay...
I heard there is a new game in the arcade!
We should check it out!
I bet it's rad!
I bet can land the highest score before anyone else can!
Nerdiest kid!
Oh!
Candy!
25 cents for candy?
I could eat candy for the rest of my life!
Mom wouldn't like that though!
I need more tokens!
I think I lost mine in the ball pit!
Where the fuck am I?
What year is this?
Yo dude!
Rad clothes!
Haven't seen a get up like that before!
It's a shirt and jacket!
Thank you!
Bro this kid is wearing a jacket too!
This kid is...
Yo dude!
A shirt and jacket?
Never seen that before!
I like your future of the flashback shirt!
That's my favorite old movie!
Old?
What are you talking about?
That movie came out like 3 weeks ago!
Oh I went back in time!
Chill out!
He's just messing around!
I'm Mike and that's Chip!
Got a name kid?
I'm Oswald!
Oswald?
Like the wizard!
The wizard?
Of Oz of course!
Oh yeah!
I saw that one once!
My parents called me Oz!
Guess where they got the name from?
How come we've never seen you around Oz?
Um...
You're still in my dad's buzz!
That's a good question!
Ha!
You're a fun guy!
It's okay to be the new kid in town Oz!
The new mill is bringing a lot of newbies like you into town!
New?
Brand new steel mill!
My dad works there!
Mike's dad does too!
Heck!
I bet that's where your dad got a job!
I'm sorry guys!
I'm still in my dad's ball pit!
What?
But...
Chip dude!
You're stressing the newbie out!
Let's have some fun while he settles in!
You wanna play pizza roller with us Oz?
That sounds fun!
But I don't think I'm supposed to be here!
Well...
Where else would you be?
Whoa!
What's he doing there?
Come on man!
I wanna talk about more movies with you!
It's seldom!
Follow us to the arcade!
Alright...
I don't know what's going on but...
Couldn't hurt to hang around a while!
He's hiding that gross ball pit!
And who knows when dad will show up anyway!
Yeah, dad's gonna be like 20 years too late!
Worse!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Pizza!
Alright...
Oh man!
This is some good stuff!
Oh this is uh...
This is weird!
Pirate guy!
FOXY!
I forgot!
Foxy!
Pirate guy!
Pineapple on pizza!
Pizza?
Oh, the humanity!
Alright, let's go over here.
That reminded me of the Italy vs.
Hong Kong pizza thing that happened.
Did you guys hear?
In the Olympics, for the finals for fencing, it was like Hong Kong vs.
Italy.
And then it was so close that they had to get video footage to find out who won.
Literally, because it was on the dot and they had to watch the replay like three plus times.
And then Hong Kong won and Italy was so mad and they were like, No!
Italy should have won that!
And then Hong Kong Pizza Hut did a special promotion with pineapple.
And then apparently people from Hong Kong were trolling Italians by talking about how much they love pineapple on pizza.
And...
Oh shit!
My speedrun!
Pizza flavored soda!
I don't even want a pecan!
Imagine how that tastes!
I almost forgot my speedrun!
My speedrun!
And then Pizza Hut did like a special promotion in Hong Kong where they're like, You can get super cheap pineapple on pizza!
Alright, out I go.
Alright, I'm here.
Have you ever...
Yo, have you ever played Pizza Roller, Oz?
Not Pizza Roller, but I've seen something like it.
This is the latest and greatest model from Fazbear.
So I'm not surprised.
Pretty exclusive stuff we got here.
What?
Fazbear?
Ha!
A kid who doesn't know about Fazbear?
You're a racket, dude.
Radical.
Here.
Grab a ball.
And we'll show you how to play.
You'll go up against me first.
And I'll go easy on ya.
Maybe.
Alright.
Okay, so the goal is to score as many points as possible by rolling the ball into the bullseye?
Okay.
Also, I upped the overall volume a little bit.
Sound guy.
How do I do that?
There's a ramp at the end that's gonna send...
Oh, a skee-ball!
Fazbear didn't invent skee-ball.
Oh.
Oh, a hundred.
Oh, that's hard.
Give it a try, Oz!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
I'm a natural!
Whoa!
Beginner's luck!
That's right.
I'm a gamer.
Bro, did you guys see that fucking 12-year-old kid?
That was...
That 12-year-old kid, he was like...
He got, like, top 500 on Fortnite at 9.
Top 5 Apex Predator at, like, 10.
And, like...
Radiant and Valorant at 12 years old.
That's me.
That's me, but at skee-ball.
Yeah!
There's a kid that got, like, Radiant and Valorant at fucking 12 years old!
And he was, like, Apex Predator at, like, 10.
And then, like, top 500 in Fortnite at, like, 9.
Bro, who...
What the fuck?
People were, like, wait, ban this kid.
He's not 13 yet.
That's so funny.
People were, like, wait a minute!
Ban him!
He's not 13 yet!
He shouldn't even be here!
He's, like, how dare you!
Okay.
I hit the wall.
Bouncy CS.
School?
Do you go to Westbrook, too?
Well, duh.
Westbrook is the only one.
Westbrook is the only school around here.
All right.
Let's see.
He's just trying to distract me.
No!
And he beat it!
And he did distract me!
I hear we're gonna have a new teacher this year.
It worked!
I think her name is Ms. Nee-Chan.
No!
Let's pause.
Let's not.
Let's make it a good roll.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe.
Oh, yes!
I won my 10 points!
Let's go!
Wow.
Somebody beat me.
That was some fun rolling, Oz.
Fun science experiment.
Would a pineapple pizza hater spontaneously combust if given a bacon pineapple hot dog?
They give a super chat to your heart.
Thank you.
How about we play some tag instead?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
That'll give us a chance to show Oz around the place.
Okay.
Which one is the nerd?
Like, which one is this guy?
I can't tell if this is Chip or this is Chip.
Or this is Mike.
I say sure.
Rad.
They're both nerds.
Yeah, but it's the 80s.
The one with the glasses is, like, super nerd.
Rad.
I'll be it for sure.
Get ready to run.
Okay, so this is Chip.
Oh, shit.
Don't get caught.
I know what to do.
The door's locked.
No!
Now I don't know what to do!
I know what to do.
They can't catch me if I'm in the ball pit.
Oh.
I got you!
I tripped!
How did I trip!
I got you!
What?!
I was like, if it's gonna do me!
I can't believe I tripped!
This place is packed today.
I feel like I couldn't outrun you at all, Chip!
I think I'm making the night.
Everyone's gonna get in there.
How about hide and seek then?
Now that's a game I'm good at.
You're on.
Okay.
This time.
This time I can hide in the ball pit.
Right?
There's no way I can't hide here.
No!
Where do I hide?
Give me a sec.
No, it's still locked.
Where do I hide?
Everything is locked.
It's not fair.
Where do you hide?
Okay.
Maybe in the arcade?
Is there a hiding spot in the arcade?
Oh, oh, here, here, here.
Oh, no.
Maybe here.
Oh, an empty suit.
Oh, it wasn't even timed.
I bet they never check in there.
June 1985?
This really is just like the movie.
I hear footsteps.
Better hide.
Oh.
Hungry?
Order now.
Wait, the tripping is random?
I need to grab it.
I can't believe I tripped on the one time I needed to run.
The mirror shows how much noise you're making.
Stay quiet.
Wait, does it track my mic?
I hope mic didn't hear that.
Gotta hide fast.
Okay.
Wouldn't it be funny if that kid dies?
In game.
I'm trying to like... trying to fucking open my tissue box.
Alright.
There you go.
Nice try, but I can hear ya, chit.
Where did you... whatever.
Did you find Oz yet?
Not yet.
He's quiet, unlike you.
Well, maybe I'll find him.
I'll find him first.
Guys, he can't vent yet.
Among Us...
Among Us hasn't been invented yet, guys.
They'll never find me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I didn't realize I was supposed to not breathe.
I was like, hey, what's that?
I thought I was a cutsy.
I was like, whoa.
What's he doing there?
What on earth was that thing?
Glad he didn't see me.
Probably not supposed to be back there.
Here.
Whoa.
What's going on?
Scared woman?
Oh my god, there's the parents!
Grab
the kids!
I don't want anybody to think about the children!
Hello?
Anyone there?
Chip?
Mike?
Crap.
Yelling is useless.
Too many people screaming.
Where are they?
Maybe they know what's going on.
Come on!
No, it's locked.
Something is blocking it.
Okay.
Can I go here?
It won't budge.
I'll just hide.
How is there still people screaming?
Hello?
Oh, it looks like one of those sliding puzzles.
I think I need a game token.
Oh, can I grab game tokens?
Oh wait, I'm going to grab some game tokens.
Wait, how do I get the game tokens though?
I want to play some games.
Hello?
Should I just leave?
Yes.
Did I win?
Where do I go?
What do I do?
Bye.
I did it.
I won the game.
What?
What the fuck?
Why would I say?
I am the person that lives in horror games.
Wait, what?
Guys, and this is why I hope you enjoyed this video.
I am the person that... I am the person that would survive in a horror... in a horror movie.
I literally would... I don't care.
I don't care if my best friend is like trapped in there.
I...
If I know I...
Guys, what's the point of going back to die?
One of us should survive.
One of us needed to survive.
Alright?
Oh my god, we did it everybody!
We beat FNAF!
Holy shit!
All I'm saying is that...
Guys, like what's the point?
If we both die, then what's the point?
Might as well have somebody survive.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She beat it!
Let's go!
Congrats!
Gamer of the year!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
I liked how the game was like...
Was like, are you sure you want to leave?
And I had zero hesitation.
I was like, yes.
Okay, let's play...
It's okay, let's not leave.
Okay guys, let's...
I love how it's like, are you sure?
Alright, confirmed.
Alright, here we go.
Let's not leave this time.
Sandy, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright, down we go.
I mean, everybody else was running out.
Of course I was gonna follow them.
Everybody else ran out.
Why would I go into danger?
They're clearly running away from danger.
Why would I go?
This is why I'm...
This is so stupid.
Like, look, they're all running away!
They're all running away!
Why would I go back into danger?
Hello?
Hey.
Come with me?
If I want to live?
Okay.
Let me follow the scary rabbit guy.
Into like, the room of danger.
Is it asking me to follow it?
Maybe it has Chip and Mike.
What?
What the fuck was that?
Hello?
What is that?
Someone has to...
Yeah!
Someone has to live to tell a story!
And then I can sell the rights to my story!
Thank you for the super chat, Aura!
Thank you!
There's no way someone ate two pizzas while running out of here.
Creepy!
Okay, that is not what we should be, like, focusing on.
Wait, where do I go?
Like, here?
Why can't I run now?
Was he here?
I need to follow that thing.
Oh, this was where...
I'm sorry, I couldn't tell where he went.
There's so many doors.
Hello?
Whoa!
Oh shit, not hello!
Okay.
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
There you go.
Where is he?
Wait, escape?
There's no way he can look under the table.
Right?
Hello?
Is he just gonna stand here and cat me?
Goodbye.
Is...
Is it gone?
I gotta get out of here.
Hope, Chip, and Mike are okay?
Can I just leave now?
Alright, goodbye.
Oh, I need to find them?
I literally just met them!
I...
I beat them in Arcade and that's it!
That's literally it!
They have no...
Oh.
Oh, they're freaking angry.
Oh my god, he has like blood eyes.
They're a little freaky.
They're doing some freaky dances now.
Can I hide in the ball pit?
Oh, I'm getting chased.
There he is.
Oh, there's a FNAF thing in the background!
Oswald!
What were you thinking?
Hiding that nasty old thing!
Didn't you hear me calling you?
Dad!
Dad, no!
At least I still have mom.
Oh, shit.
Jeff?
What the fuck?
What am I pulling?
Dad?
Wait, what?
Dad, did you see that?
Jeff's my new dad now.
Dad, are you...
No, he got spring-trapped!
Wait, what?
Wait, that's not dad!
Dad, are you okay?
Come on, son.
Have a good night, guys.
Wait, Jeff!
I think something's wrong with dad!
I don't think grown men are supposed to have glowing eyes!
You look different there, dad.
Did you get a new haircut?
He looks fine to me.
That's probably...
He's gonna start calling you boy.
That's probably gone to your head.
Go home and relax.
Wait, wait!
Jeff, please!
Oswald's house.
Night one.
The longer Oswald...
What did you do to my dad?
Where are you taking me?
How do you even know how to...
How do you even know how to drive?
What the...
Oh, that's creepy.
That's actually creepy.
My house?
Wait, how do you know where I live?
Wait, that's fucked up!
How did you know?
You a doxer?
Is he gonna bang my...
I'll just be going to my room for the night now, okay?
DMV gave this animatronic a license.
What's happening?
What should I do?
Oh my god, why do I have drawings of the FNAF characters?
Oh, I'll call mom!
He used the force!
I knew it!
Maybe she'll know what to do.
Dad always leaves his cell phone at home.
I bet it's in his room.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta...
Dad got me this lava lamp from the yard sale.
Pretty retro.
I thought it was cool.
Bro, what the fuck do I...
Oh, I have to hide under my bed too.
Okay.
Okay, so like...
And why didn't he kill me right away?
He could've easily left me out to die in the middle of the street.
Why would I need to hide now?
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Okay.
Where's my dad's room?
Is this where my dad lives?
Hallway 1.
Oh, master bedroom.
Okay.
I need to go back.
Guys, I'm reading the map.
I'm learning.
Okay.
Dad?
Hello?
I saw dad's phone on the lights down.
I need to find a way to make that thing leave first.
He's like, oh my god.
The only reason he like...
He like transferred his soul into his body is so he can experience a bed for the first time.
He's like, oh my god.
I haven't had a bed since 1945.
I can start it with a loud noise.
He's so... he's so tired.
I guess the sewing machine.
That should be loud enough.
Alright.
Hello?
What could that be?
Kringo!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
Here's the doki on my birthday.
Hope to aka next year!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Kringo!
Yeah!
Now it's time to steal dad's phone and call mom.
Happy birthday!
Is that the phone?
That has to be the phone, right?
Oh shit.
Alright, let me call her right now.
Where are the numbers?
Does dad still just remember them all?
Fucking 911.
What the fuck?
Mom's number should be written somewhere in the house.
Just call 911!
What the fuck?
Did I not teach my kid?
Dad didn't teach the kid to fucking call 911?
He gets three numbers!
It's literally three numbers!
Dad of the year.
Apparently my parents didn't teach me how to call 911.
Like, okay.
Let's see.
555-5683.
Okay, five...
Oh!
Wait.
Nine-nine...
Oh!
Okay guys, I was just very stupid.
Nine...
Wait.
Wait, I...
What?
I...
I called 991.
I'm sorry.
No!
That's not what I meant!
I'm messing it up!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, there we go.
Hello!
Please!
Unfortunately, 911 services happened.
Wait, is that illegal?
I've been suspended in your area.
Not too poor for the police?
Please call your local police station.
This is an emergency!
What the fuck is the local police station number?
Well...
That's great.
Alright.
Who you gonna call?
Okay.
555-5683.
555-568...
No!
Okay.
83.
There we go.
Hello, Mom!
Hello?
Mom, it's an emergency!
What's going on, sweetie?
It's Zed!
Something's wrong!
What's going on?
Okay.
I'll be right there.
Wait.
What's the Ghostbusters number?
Oh, shit!
The closet!
The closet never fucks up!
Woo!
Okay.
We're good.
Oh.
Wait.
Where do we meet Mom?
That must be Mom.
That's Mom!
Wait.
What?
That must be Mom!
Wait.
Where's Mom?
Where the fuck's Mom?
Do I...
Go to the living room?
Oh, outside!
Okay.
We gotta make it.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
These jump scares are so good.
Oh, God.
We don't hesitate.
We don't care.
Mom!
You're a doctor?
How...
Can that replace?
Is this some kind of prank, Oswald?
Dad looks fine.
You should look no better than to fake an emergency while I'm at work.
But...
Can you see it?
I see that Dad is fine.
I don't know what's gotten into you.
But go to your room and calm down.
I'll get back to the hospital.
But Dad's not even talking!
Mom!
Dad's not even talking!
Oh.
It's all up to me, I guess.
Dad has to be stuck in the ball pit.
I gotta get back to...
How the fuck am I gonna get back to Jeff's?
I can't drive.
I'm like a child.
Okay.
Find a way to escape.
Is this just not the door?
Like...
He's just standing there menacingly.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck...
Where do I...
Where do I go?
Go through the window?
Do I have a window?
Oh, I do.
The latch is rusted shut.
I think I can still unscrew the bolts.
Gotta find a screwdriver.
We all know there is a screwdriver in the attic.
Right?
I don't...
I don't fucking know.
There has to be a...
No!
In the basement!
The basement always has a screwdriver.
Screw driving.
Cause that's where you do like screw driving things.
Goodbye.
Oh shit!
Died!
I clicked the first thing I saw!
It was the first thing I saw!
Okay.
Alright.
I think we're fine.
Wait, but we're...
I have a garage?
No!
There's no fucking garage here!
It's alright.
Everything's fine.
Where the fuck would...
Where would a screwdriver be?
It'd be in tools, right?
Yeah.
Or battery.
Could be useful.
I'll grab the rope too.
What's this?
Weight resistant mechanism?
What the fuck is that?
Weight resistant...
A series of weights and levers that can resist a joystick's movement?
Okay, I have rope and I have battery.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I have like...
Okay, here we go.
It's not a screwdriver.
That's a drill.
No.
But the lights have to be...
The lights have to be on.
I feel like...
I don't think there's anything here.
Oh no, I'm worried of going outside.
Make a Scooby Doo trap for dad.
Where the fuck is my cat?
A flashlight?
Cat!
Dad?
What if I just go back to my room?
What if I...
I just...
I feel safe in my room.
Okay.
Got a finally screwdriver.
Alright.
I don't feel safe at all.
Oh my god, I'm so tense.
I'm actually so tense right now.
This is so scary.
Then it has to be in the attic.
Plumbing.
Five, five, five, five.
Three, two, five.
Five, five, five.
Two, two, seven, seven.
Do these numbers work?
Yeah, do they work?
Okay.
Five, five, five, five.
What was the plumbing?
What was the numbers?
Five, five, five.
Oh, contacts list.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Five, five, five, five.
Two, two, seven.
Might as well.
Hello?
Oh.
Guys, they called on me.
Did I got it wrong?
Five, five, five.
Two, two, seven, seven.
Hello?
Hello, Joe's mechanic.
How can I help you?
Do you know anything about animatronics?
Oh my god, Oswald.
No.
Tell them to call the cops.
You got the wrong number, kid.
Okay.
You should've called the cops!
I heard a door.
Oh, I heard a door.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Oh.
Don't look through.
You should've told them to call the cops!
Why would I be late?
Hey, do you know anything about fucking animatronics?
God damn it, child.
Oh, god.
Where do I go?
Dining room?
I thought I could go to the attic.
Who the fuck is he?
The fuck's the screwdriver?
Can't I just leave?
Wait, I can just leave.
Okay.
All right, pizzeria.
I can just leave.
Okay.
I guess I'll just leave.
I mean, that works.
You're here late, kid.
Your parents know you're here.
Did I just walk all the way here?
My dad drove me last time.
Did I really walk here?
Yeah, dad burnt dinner, so emergency pizza.
What was he making?
You can just leave.
Ramen noodles.
As in the microwave kind?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, been there.
Forgot to add water once and the smell haunts you forever.
All right, time to go to the ball pit.
Yeah, where the fuck is the police station?
All right, off to the ball pit I'll go.
Here?
Is it this one?
No, it's the what, the furthest.
Like, I don't know, I oh my god there's the tripping mechanic there.
Sure do love that.
All right, into the ball pit I go back to 1985.
For the bite of 22.
Okay, now I gotta find dad?
Dad?
Wait, is that kid crying?
Maybe they need help.
No, is it Balloon Boy or the Puppet Guy?
I feel like your eyes are watching my every move.
Oh hey, I got wooden balls.
Oh, the animatronics are gone.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that kid's gonna die.
Hello, child.
Help me, I can't get out!
How did you get in there?
Something grabbed me and stuck me in.
It feels like this suit is gonna...
This is the Bite of 35!
It feels like this suit is gonna snap shut.
I think I can loosen the bolts with a screwdriver.
I'll find one.
Okay.
The door is locked.
Oh no, where the fuck is a screwdriver?
Where would a screwdriver even be?
Oh no.
I'm trying!
I don't know where the fuck screwdrivers are!
A coupon?
Oh, but a coupon though.
A coupon for Foxy's Pirates Palooza.
I mean, I guess... Oh, money.
Okay, I should...
No, I didn't.
The door is locked.
Wait...
Where would this...
Nope, you saw what happened last time.
Yeah, I won the game.
Did I have to go back?
I don't have a screwdriver!
Oh, the door is locked!
I don't know where the screwdriver is!
How
does it get the screw...
Dude, that's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
That's actually so...
Wait, no, no, no.
You're gay.
Wait, we're...
Back here!
Okay, backstage.
There must be a screwdriver backstage.
I look even creepier torn...
Torn apart.
Like, the shelf has... was some kind of hunter's...
trophy...
display.
A fuse box!
Dad's once shown me how to use one of those!
The wallet belongs to Dad!
He has to be here somewhere!
All right, kid.
I will save you one day.
You will get saved one day!
What the fuck?
Why am I ringing?
What?
Battery wouldn't buzz?
One day...
Do I...
Oh!
Oh, that is not good.
I wonder if Jess has the same key.
Oh!
Hey, guys!
I fucked up!
I didn't realize that's what batteries were for!
I used up my one battery!
No!
I was curious!
I was like, what's that?
Guys, you can tell that I'm learning.
All right, we got to grab the screwdriver from...
Grab a key from Jeff.
Jeff, I need a screwdriver.
Maybe I can open these doors.
Maybe there's a screwdriver here.
Door is locked.
Oh, my God, please.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I got control panel.
That has to be important, right?
Oh, okay.
This is the arcade.
Has to be like a screwdriver here, right?
I got an electron gun.
I have everything but a fucking screwdriver!
Please.
No, it's actually at home.
No, I don't want to go back home!
Can I save my game?
No, okay.
All right.
I guess...
I guess we actually do have to go back home.
Okay, but let's grab all the items we can first.
Before we go home.
I can't believe it.
Like, is that kid actually important enough?
Do I actually care about the child?
Do you have a key to the basement, Jeff?
First the ball pit, now the basement?
Are you that bored, kid?
Um, yes.
Just feel like exploring.
Well, let's make a deal.
Just between you and me.
I don't pay for trash and forgot to dump a bag at the mill earlier.
Go take that trash over here and I'll give you the key when you get back.
But take that flashlight.
Gets pretty dark right here.
Around here.
Thanks, but the battery's pretty low.
Dig around the trash or you'll run out.
Probably all sorts of interesting things in there.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Hold.
I just used my little...
Guys, wouldn't it be great if I had that other battery just then?
Wouldn't...
All right.
Time to go home.
Back home I go.
All right.
Night one.
Okay.
Gotta grab the screwdriver.
Hey, Dad, I'm home.
I'm back.
I'm not going...
No!
I can't even...
Are you serious?
I didn't know.
I thought I could grab the screwdriver back home.
All right.
What's this?
Oh, hey.
More battery.
Where the fuck do I...
Did I get one guide?
Apparently, I got one guide.
Okay.
I gotta do the mill.
Apparently, it's not even home.
Somebody said I got one guide.
God fucking damn it.
I always get one guide.
All right.
The mill closed down three years ago.
Almost everything else in this town has been closed since then.
All right.
Time to throw the trash.
Bag of trash.
I mean, that's not too bad.
All right.
I did it.
Pizzeria.
Hello.
How late does this place open?
I don't know.
Hey, Jeff.
Oh.
Jeff, I did it.
All done.
Thanks, kid.
Saved my ache and back.
Here's the key as promised.
All right.
Nice.
Time to head over to...
As long as Jeff is not dead, I know I'm safe.
Doki, you left a shotgun at home.
You can't believe me because I paid $5 to tell you this.
Dori, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I wish Jeff was my new dad.
All right.
We go this way.
And then we go behind here.
How can Jeff be my dad?
All right.
There you go.
I have so many stuff in my inventory now.
Oh.
I don't like that.
I didn't...
Oh!
Why do I...
Why do I do that every time?
Just when I need the screwdriver!
It's fine.
Nothing bad is going to happen to me.
All right.
The screwdriver was here all along.
Wait.
Can I do this?
Okay.
I can't get...
Child, don't worry.
Oh, fuck.
I tripped.
Child, don't...
Don't worry.
Child!
What if I just leave him?
Get out!
Wait.
Mike?
No, that's not you.
You both wear glasses.
So I thought you were...
One second.
Thanks.
I thought I was going to be stuck in there forever.
One second.
I was talking to my friend and then...
What's that?
Oh, that sounds like him.
He might be in danger.
Come on.
We got to find him together.
Nice.
I have bait.
I can run faster than him.
Never mind.
Let's get out of here.
Bro, see?
That's me.
It's like one of us has to live.
Wait.
I'm looking for my dad.
You haven't seen tall man wearing a blue shirt, have you?
That kid's using my strategy.
You mean like an adult?
No, I haven't.
Look, man.
I wish I could help you but...
Wow!
He can't find me!
You find me!
How did he...
How did he find me?
Yes, he can.
Wait.
I got an idea.
I got it.
He can't find me twice.
I'm crazy!
Okay.
Okay, guys, guys, I have an idea.
Now that I know, now that I know what the QuickTime event was...
How far was I supposed to know he found me?
Okay, skip.
Okay, wait, guys.
Guys, that QuickTime event was inhumane.
Okay, guys, watch this.
Guys.
Guys, I got this, guys.
Watch this, guys.
Guys, it's gonna work, guys.
Okay, can't find me this time.
Oh, that's a flashlight!
Okay, now I know what the key was.
Guys, how the fuck was I supposed to know that was a flashlight?
It said press F, so I assume it was a QuickTime event.
Okay.
I thought it was a QTE!
It says press F!
Why didn't it turn...
Okay, now!
Now I know what to do.
For real.
Now, I figured it out.
The motherfucking F showed up!
Okay, now for realsies.
Okay.
All right, we gotta hide.
All right, child.
It's your fault.
Okay.
I'm trying my best.
There's no way.
There's no way!
No!
I was offscreen!
How did he...
Everybody knows when you're offscreen, you don't see anything after that.
Where do I hide?
Like, where the fuck do I hide in this...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay, now I know.
I...
Bro has eyes.
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys.
I figured it out.
Yeah, but, like, he has to travel to the next screen.
How did he know?
He still had to travel to the next screen, guys.
That's all I'm saying.
How did he know?
Now!
Guys, do you think I'm gonna...
Guys, do you think I'm gonna beat the speedrun record?
Bro is actually stream sniping!
He is!
There's no way he knew!
Like, I was on the next screen!
How did he fucking know?
Please.
Please, child.
Child, run.
Run for your fucking life, child!
Please!
Why are you walking, child?
Open the door faster!
Okay.
There we go.
There's no way.
You can't tell this time!
What the fuck?!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
There we go.
We did it.
It would be funny if I just came out of the chest right now.
Not the fucking spiders!
I have to swat the spiders!
Bro, I think typing up the dead.
I don't fucking remember where the letters are.
Hey.
We did it.
Okay.
Yay!
All right.
He must be gone now, right?
Can I do the fuse?
Oh, my God.
It's good.
We get the...
We get the trips out of the way right now.
Where do I go?
Escape?
Can I just go home?
Like, I just...
Go back.
Go back to the ball pit.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
I'm home now.
I didn't get a lot of time to look for Dad.
I got tripped over five times.
The achievement.
But I gotta think of a better plan first.
I'm sorry, Dad.
Stay safe until I get back.
All right.
Bye, Dad.
I guess...
I guess Springtrap's my new father now.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm having a nightmare.
Oh, I'm just gonna eat with him?
Like, does he...
Where's his plate?
Give Daddy a hug!
Yay!
No!
Was it all just a dream?
I guess I should start a day then.
That's so cool now.
Cat!
Is this all just a dream?
Cat, why did you let this happen?
Wait, I can unscrew this.
No way.
What?
Oh, my God.
Outside?
No way.
What do you mean, no way?
Like...
Okay.
No, fuck the environment.
Keeping the lights on.
Get breakfast.
Okay.
All right.
My rising six.
It has arisen.
Oh, no.
Not only do I have to deal with puberty, but I have to deal with my fucking dad.
My springtrap dad.
Huh?
The first day of school.
Are you still asleep, young man?
I hope not.
Had the strangest dream about dad.
No, I have to worry about girls too.
Don't worry.
Your dad is fine.
He's waiting for you in the dining room.
What?
All right.
Let's go to the dining room.
Hello, dad.
Um, maybe I'll just skip breakfast today.
Well, your dad wanted to eat with you this morning.
Um, maybe another morning.
Well, don't forget your lunch.
So you don't starve today.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Hey, dad.
What if I just go to dad and be like, hi.
That's fucking creepy, dad.
Wait, would I be able to...
Oh, I should pull up the attic.
I should go explore now that he's not going to kill me.
Mom used to rock me to sleep on this when I was a baby.
All right.
Whoa!
That's a lot of spiders.
Okay.
I'm just going to...
Now that dad's not going to kill me yet, I can, like, loot a little bit.
Kiss him goodbye!
I mean, that's cool.
William Afton is my father now.
I mean, that's pretty cool, I guess.
I mean, you know, not a lot of kids can tell their friends that your dad's a murderer.
That's pretty cool.
All right.
Let's see.
Dad wouldn't mind.
I can go into his room too.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there's so many batteries!
Let's see...
Looks like there's some text here from yesterday.
Some pictures of my family.
Mom and dad at Halloween.
Grandma holding us as a baby.
Alright.
Springtrap over cooties.
Look at the super chatter.
He's like, thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Can I grab cat food?
Okay, I want to make sure I grab everything before I head off.
Because apparently...
Apparently, dad's not going to kill me right now.
Alright, time to go to school.
Bye, dad.
Bye, Springtrap dad.
No, that's what I said, TD!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, does that mean like...
You know...
You know, like...
Because mom doesn't know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Am I going to get like...
Am I going to get brother?
Am I going to get a brother?
Alright, school time.
Yeah!
Okay.
Hello.
Hello, guys.
I can't stop thinking about that thing.
I wish I could just run away.
Who would eat lunch at a time like this?
You sure that's a good idea, Jet?
You can leave and you're going to be such a chicken.
Wait, where's me?
Oh, I'm over there.
Okay.
Hey, who did that?
Run!
Oh, shit.
What's this?
I wonder if that kid...
Am I going to stuff dad Phil with fireworks?
Okay, everyone.
Let's start heading back to class.
Oh, are these the bad boys?
Hey, it smells like fresh meat.
Um, that would just be my lunch.
Oswald the Osta has forgotten how to eat?
That was like the one thing you could do right.
Hahaha.
Good one, Dylan.
Oh my god, these children.
Oh, what's wrong with these kids?
Oh, they are nerds.
Okay.
My family has three cats.
I love cats.
I have two dogs.
I have a rabbit.
I hate rabbits.
This is why you can't make friends, Oswald.
Oh my god.
This is exactly why nobody wants to be your friend.
Settle down, class.
Remember, the bell has to ring before you.
Ring, ring, ring, ring.
Dismissed.
Oswald kind of sucks.
Yeah, he's a little bitch.
Yes, did you need something, Oswald?
Teacher?
My dad is an animatronic.
I need...
No, nothing, Mrs. Mee-Cham.
My family used to go to the roller rink after the first day of school.
At least you got a goal.
I'll never get to...
get to now that it's gone.
I'd much rather sit at home and play some Field Forge anyway.
I think you mean start on my Washington Urban essay, don't you?
Teacher, you're not supposed to eavesdrop on us.
That's rude.
I can't believe we actually did work on the first day of school.
Huh?
We did work today?
Oh, shit.
This kid's gonna fail.
I mean, it's sixth grade.
Middle school doesn't count.
Middle school does not count...
because it doesn't go on your permanent record.
So why try?
Alright, what's the school...
layout like?
Okay, is there anything I can steal?
Is Field Forge like Minecraft?
Yeah, I was like wondering what...
what Field Forge is.
Okay, can I steal anything?
Oh, what's this?
A voucher validator.
Love is love.
I have dad, a mom, and my mom's animatronic.
Animatronic boyfriend.
Thank you for the super chat, Dory.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Looks like there's a pep rally on Friday.
Should be really fun.
Hey, you're the firecracker kid.
The name's Jet.
That has a nice ring to it too.
Do you have any more I could borrow?
First off, kid.
You can't just borrow a firecracker.
You're kind of a one-time use only.
Okay, then.
Can you give me one?
Do you have any idea what these things cost?
Yeah, aren't they illegal in America?
Tell you what.
I'm usually at the library after school.
What the fuck kind of tough kid are you?
Why are you at the library?
Bring me something I couldn't get anywhere else.
And maybe we can trade.
What the fuck?
Are you a nerd?
What the fuck are you doing at the library?
Time to pull out the fire alarm.
Oh my god, there's the nerds.
Please cheer us on in the regional volleyball tournament.
I know we can win it all this year.
Okay, I don't really care about these children.
You won't believe what happened in science class today.
We tried to make a volcano model and it exploded all over the teacher.
It really made the classroom...
Okay, I don't care about you either.
All right.
All right, let's see if I can steal anything from the principal.
A framed article from the school newspaper.
The headlines about the time we won a kickball tournament.
The teacher has nothing?
What the fuck?
This is the principal's office.
How can it not have anything useful?
Oh, no, the spider.
Okay, there must be...
Oh, just...
Never mind.
It's just garbage.
Okay, not even batteries?
I know, right?
The fuck is the...
Oh, wait, can I steal his basketball?
Oh, I can't.
I can't steal anything here.
What does the...
What does this guy want?
I don't know.
Do I have stuff right now for the...
For the punk?
How about you read a book?
On how not to be a loser?
Oh!
Ha!
Come on, guys.
Let's stop wasting time on this nerds.
Bro, they're fucking headed to the library.
Don't listen to them.
Dylan's just jealous because you know how...
Bro, we're in sixth grade.
What do you mean by that?
We're in sixth...
Oh, my...
Dylan should not be in sixth grade if he still doesn't know how to read.
Thank you.
The bullies picked on me for reading at my old school.
What's wrong?
We're in sixth grade.
We're supposed to know how to read.
Well, that must be pretty stupid.
I read a ton of sci-fi.
What are you reading?
Ancient...
Oh, no.
This is a nerd.
Nerd!
Ancient...
Who the fuck reads ancient Greek mythology at sixth grade?
I did.
Oh, I've been meaning to get around to that one.
It's not much different from science fiction, really.
It's all about being brave during impossible situations.
Well, if you ever want to read something with pictures in it, I'd be happy to lend you a comic.
Oh, if you like art, you'll actually have a use for this thing.
I was helping my grandpa clear out some junk yesterday and found his old sketchbook.
There's some neat drawings.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I love free stuff.
Is it this?
What the fuck?
No...
Bro!
What?
You didn't think this was weird?
New behavior.
Chica is making garbage nests make employees aware all garbage needs taken out before closing.
Wait.
His...
Her grandpa used to work...
Wait.
Is her grandpa the security guard?
Any voice...
Is that the purple?
Everybody is the purple.
He's the purple guy.
Why does he keep screaming?
Keep bright flashes away from Freddy's suit sends him into a frenzy.
Remember, the dark eyes are always watching.
AI programming causes Freddy to stalk partygoers by guarding doors.
Tech tool is in.
Everybody is a purple guy.
Okay.
Oh, there's the birthday.
It bites.
Keep fingers away.
Recent security update fried the AI.
Chica stuck in preservation.
Protocol.
Okay.
What's this?
Chica will bring so and full to the pile and eat it.
Oh.
All right.
So it's like nesting.
Crested.
Oh, it was changed.
We dumped offsite.
Oh, here's like Bonnie's guitars.
Full suit.
Padding.
Exoskeleton.
Oh, it is stickers.
All right.
That's interesting.
Okay.
No way.
He used to be some kind of technician.
So they're just doodles and notes from his old job.
He didn't want to talk about it, though.
I was supposed to throw it away, but didn't want to waste paper, you know?
Haha.
Yeah.
I'm Gabriella, by the way.
I'm Oswald.
This is an interesting sketchbook, Gabriella.
Thanks.
All right.
What's this?
I can't go back in.
Okay.
I don't care.
Apparently...
Have you checked out that new game, WrestleQuest?
My dad was telling me all about the different wrestlers.
I don't know how much about wrestling going in, but I do now.
Okay.
Where's the...
Where's the fucking Vtuber fan?
We were saying the Vtuber fan was here.
Where's the Vtuber kid?
I want to know what he looks like.
Is that you?
No, that's the gamer student.
Where the fuck is...
Is it the...
That's the observant student.
Where the fuck is the Vtuber fan?
Someone said he's like here.
It can't be these guys.
These guys are talking about pets.
Where are the Vtuber kids?
Okay.
That's still the guy that's like cheering me on.
Bro, talk to everybody.
Talk to all of them.
Because this is like the second...
This is the classroom.
Did he...
Did he got...
Did he got beat up?
Did he...
Somebody threw...
Wait.
What?
You can go inside?
Oh my God.
You can open doors?
Who are you?
Oh my God.
This is crazy.
AI...
AI is so crazy.
They can open doors now.
They...
They actually...
Okay.
I'm fucking leaving.
We can't...
The Vtuber child isn't here.
All right.
We time to go home.
Oh, sorry.
Wrong place.
Went to the mirror.
Day two.
Okay.
All right.
Not here.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Did you guys hear that?
All right.
Time to go.
Oh.
To the lock...
The locker?
Wait.
What?
In the locker?
I'm not getting one guy.
I am...
I know for a fact that he's not in the locker.
You can't fucking trick me.
Okay.
He wants to...
He wants to get in there.
It's a locker.
He went to see his Oshii.
His Oshii streams at 5 p.m.
PST.
He had to get there in time.
All right.
Let's see.
Go home.
Hello, dad.
I'm home.
Don't you have to go to work?
Like, doesn't he have to go to...
Go to his, like, 9 to 5?
I don't know.
I believe he came back from his 9 to 5.
He's like, yes I did it.
I successfully possessed another soul.
Oh my god.
And then he still has to go to work.
Oh yeah, he has to work part time at the corner store.
Bro, he's like a 7-Eleven.
He works at a 7-Eleven.
Oh my god, even Springtrap needs to get a job.
Time to go back to Jeff.
I think I have a plan now.
Gotta get out here first.
He needs that money.
He needs to make sure the wife doesn't know something's up.
Oh, I can just leave like that.
That's convenient now.
Alright.
He's gotta press the boot.
The new boot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine finally getting a body possessed and return from the afterlife only to realize you need to pay taxes again.
And you have to work part time.
Dude, that's the worst part.
You have to do minimum wage.
I feel bad for him.
You literally came back to fucking work at the bite of 7-Eleven.
Is that the bite of 7-Eleven?
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Wait, there's another lady here?
I sing forever to get my pizza.
I swear.
The longer I wait, the more I can hear the rats in the wall.
Like, what if the kitchen has rats?
Even worse, what if the cooks are rats?
Don't tell me to calm down.
You know I have mouse-a-phobia.
Seems distracted and paranoid.
But they told me in Ratatouille that if there's rats in the kitchen, that means...
That means the kitchen is like super hygienic, right?
I've seen Jeff use this before.
Oh, does that mean I can go in here?
No?
Oh wait, that should work.
I have the key for this.
Yeah, in Ratatouille.
In Ratatouille.
Like, they make really good...
They make really good food.
Ratatouille wouldn't lie to me.
Okay, I want to make sure that...
That I have everything here.
I feel like I don't really need to use the flashlights.
I can sort of see what's going on.
Alright.
Back to the ball pit at goal.
Alright, time.
Ball pit time-traveling machine.
Ball pit time machine.
It's like the hot tub time machine, but with more balls.
I heard before.
Wonder where it came from.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine if Oswald convinces everyone Dad is a robot.
But instead of people freaking out, Springtrap just gets confiscated by scientists for study.
That's a happy ending.
But like, oh...
Okay.
Well, it's obviously back here.
What's this?
Yay!
I did it!
Alright, find Dad.
Where could Dad be?
Better be careful.
Where's the crying from?
Oh, I don't like this.
Wow!
No!
What do you mean he's still walking while I was trying to fucking get...
Oh, okay.
I'm literally in a dialogue scene and he's still walking towards me?
That's fucked.
I swear to God if I trip, I swear to fucking God if I trip.
Okay.
Oh, no.
It's spider time.
Oh, God.
I'm swatting the spiders.
Okay.
I know where my letters are.
How's he still walking around?
I can't believe I talked to him a long time.
What is this?
Alright here we go.
The spider quick time events.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
There's money.
I like money.
Alright.
He has to be gone now, right?
I can't just walk out right now.
That's fucked!
That's not fair!
Oh no!
Is he still there?
I'm just gonna walk.
Oh, I hear him.
He used the door, but which door?
It has to be the first door.
Okay, I actually have to walk now.
Okay.
Where's the other kid?
The door is locked?
Then where the fuck do I go?
Yes!
Seriously!
Like, where do I go?
Like...
He's over in that door though!
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him.
I forgot what this minigame was.
He didn't see me, so he can't know.
There's no way he knows.
He didn't see me.
Okay.
I'm good.
I'm gonna walk.
I was like, JK.
And then I saw the meter.
I was like, never mind.
I shall walk now.
Where's the crying coming from?
Is she here?
Oh, he just wants food.
Okay.
He's just hungry.
Okay, bye chica!
He's just...
Okay.
Does that thing even have a stomach?
How did it smell my lunch from that far away?
Alright.
That's definitely a kid in the kitchen.
But I can't get them to lure that thing back to it's weird nest.
Oh, I need to find food!
If it was my one's food, maybe I could get a pizza slice, a pizza from Jeff.
Okay, so I have to go back.
Oh, and I hate the rat noises.
No!
That's nothing!
That's so funny!
Am
I stuck?
There's no way he knows.
There's no way he knows, right?
There's no way.
Are you serious?
That's so...
That's so funny!
That's actually so funny!
Bro, what the fuck!
I'm venting?
I'm...
Can I... I'm venting?
Oh!
I am venting!
Oh.
Okay.
Whoops.
Well.
Nevermind.
Wait, is that really... I forgot to...
I forgot to remove the boxes, guys.
I...
Never after.
Is he still there?
I hear him.
Oh, God.
How does he go back and forth from dead?
Maybe, like, when he's at the part-time job.
He, like, fucking leaves.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
That is actually bullshit.
I can't believe!
I can't believe the moment I walk out the door, he was there.
That is so bullshit.
Holy shit.
Like, what are the odds?
What are the odds?
Oh, I should really...
I'll fix that later.
I wanna go back to my ball pit time machine.
I don't wanna deal with that right now.
Okay.
He is!
He is a stream sniper!
I guess it goes to five nights.
Because we're at night number two.
So, like, following...
Oh, hey, Jeff!
Hey, Jeff!
Do you have an extra slice of pizza that you could give me?
Sorry, kid.
You know things have been tough lately.
You want something, you gotta buy it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
What do I do now?
I can't afford to buy anything.
I could just borrow a slice from the kitchen.
I have this random rat trap I found.
I bet a rat chase will get Jeff away from the door for sure.
Okay.
Where did I fucking put the rat trap?
Did I just put it on the ground?
Oh, no?
What the fuck do I do with the...
What do I do with the rat trap?
Maybe, like...
Just...
Put it here?
I could literally just steal the pizza from here.
He's not there!
There's pizza in there!
I see pizza!
That's a pepperoni.
I see a fucking pepperoni in that drawer.
Oh, I have to trap a rat.
Okay.
That makes more sense.
Wait.
That seems right.
I have to trap a rat.
Okay.
Is there any rats here?
Any rats?
Any rats in the basement?
How is there no rats in here?
Do I have to go all the way...
Do I have to go all the way to 1985 for my rats?
Oh, my God.
There's a rat in the ball pit.
Rat?
Where the fuck are the rats?
Where the...
I got gold.
Maybe up here?
Rat?
Wait, that's the kitchen?
Oh, the door is locked.
Okay.
Rat?
Rat, rat, rat?
God damn it!
Why is this place so clean?
How dare he make this place clean?
Can't believe it.
Why does this pizzeria not violate health codes?
I don't wanna go back to the past.
No, there has to be...
Rats did not only exist in Nigeria.
1985, guys!
There has to be rats in this timeline!
There's no way rats only existed in 1985!
No!
I can't believe it!
Rats have gotten extinct here!
Rats got extinct in this timeline.
In this timeline, there's no rats.
I forgot where we found the last rat!
Guys, where was the last rat?
I'm going back in here.
Guys, I forgot.
Where was the last rat?
I can't believe we had to steal a rat from the past.
We just got a butterfly effect!
What if I butterfly effect it?
If I bring a past rat into the current timeline...
What if the rat, that past rat, was supposed to like...
What if a war started because I told you?
I took the rat back!
The chica spot?
Oh, okay.
It's the chica spot.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I should like... I'm going to bring that box away, actually.
All I'm saying is that if I bring the rat back here in this timeline...
It'll cause so much issues!
How do I remove the boxes?
I'm so mad.
I can't even remove boxes.
Is he outside?
He's outside, isn't he?
But we'll just walk.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah, woah, woah.
Oh, that's where chica is.
Alright, guys.
Get ready to die here.
There's the rat!
Where are you going, you rat?
Nothing will come out while I'm standing.
I better leave so it comes back.
Alright.
Gotta get my rat.
Yeah!
I'm gonna bring you fly affected!
It's time for the butterfly effect!
I come back and America loses the state.
It's now...
Hahaha!
I come back.
And we don't have...
We lost Alaska.
Hahaha!
In fact, he's like, Alaska never existed.
What are you talking about?
Alaska is now owned by Canada.
Alright.
Okay, so I have to...
I'm just gonna talk to him.
You're late.
We don't sell slices after lunch.
So you want pizza?
You gotta buy a whole pie.
Oh, um, I'm good for now.
Okay, do I just like...
Oh, I guess I'll put the rat near her.
Because I'm a bitch.
Wait.
Put the rat near her.
Oh, that it is.
Oh, that should be enough to distract Jeff.
Texas becomes its own nation.
Hahaha!
Doki, Springtrap is working 9 to 5 as your dad.
And you worry a rat will affect this.
Neil, thank you.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, rat!
It's a dirty rat!
Excuse me, I'm Oswald.
You're right, town.
You picked the wrong place, pal.
Alright, you should be distracted.
The kitchen should be free now.
I just have to sneak in, grab pizza, and hurry out before Jeff comes out.
Yeah, let me sneak in.
Let me sneak in.
I'm sne...
Hahaha!
I'm sneaking!
Let's go!
There you go.
I got us a slice of pizza.
Sneaking successful.
Alright, very sneaky.
I'm so sneaky.
Alright.
Time to get caught by...
Caught by dad.
Oh.
There's no way Springtrap is not outside right now.
There's no way.
He's gonna come out that door.
He's gonna fucking kill me.
There's no way.
Okay, I keep forgetting it's this door.
Alright.
Springtrap!
I hate walking but I have to.
Not exactly how I imagined feeding a chicken.
Alright.
I go here?
Hello, Chica.
You want a little pizza?
I guess I'll go when she gets out.
When the spring shot comes out right here.
Whoa, there's a phone!
Hello?
I am?
What is it?
Phone guy?
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for the tip.
Oh, I can move!
Oh, I should have been moving!
Oh, shit!
Mike!
Us?
Is it gone?
For now.
Let's get to the exit.
I found him!
Right towards Chica!
You go!
Yeah!
Right towards Chica!
Alright, I'm walking.
I'm fucking walking through this.
I'm too scared to run now.
Like, I know this is too deep, but this game is actually pretty, like, anxiety, you know?
Mike!
Or Chip!
Aren't you...
Aren't you coming?
No, I'm looking for my dad.
He's wearing a blue shirt and has brown hair.
Have you seen him?
Have you seen my dad?
Nope.
Have you seen Chip?
Well, you were in the arcade when the power went out.
No, I haven't.
Do you think he's...
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Mike
fucking...
He actually...
He actually ran, that little fucker!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
What?!
That's fucked!
He actually ran!
That fucker!
I don't remember what this mini-game was.
Oh!
I knew it!
The flashlight worked!
Oh!
What the fuck!
Why is Chica still there?!
I knew the flashlight actually does something!
Back to my...
My ball pit time machine!
I keep trying to say hot tub time machine.
Man, that was too close.
I cannot find him.
Where have I looked?
I don't know.
Outside?
Like, Cosmo.
We can look outside.
Me pee's at the mill!
Oh, my God!
But Mike, I know will never run away.
Oswald, you know me for like 10 minutes.
Dory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Time to go home.
Oswald's house.
Day 3.
What the fuck happened to my window?!
Mom!
Isn't this weird, Mom?!
Like, what?!
How did Mom allow this?!
Oh, my God!
What can I...
Hello, Dad.
Goodbye, Dad.
What does it want now?!
How the fuck did my mom allow this?!
Understand!
It got pointed...
Mom!
Dad pointed it out!
Isn't that fucking weird, Mom?!
Like, Toki, go pet the cat, dude.
Not because they give you the super chat.
They give you the...
That's weird!
Isn't it, Mom?!
Isn't this weird?!
I thought this was weird!
Already followed that thing once.
Didn't go so well last time.
This is fine.
Mom!
Isn't this weird, Mom?!
Mom?
Where's Mom?
Good morning, Oswald.
Are you ready for...
Mom?!
Dad boarded the windows!
Oswald, tell your mom he boarded the windows!
I think I'll just eat at school today.
If that's okay.
Sure, hon.
Have you made any friends yet?
Well, there is this one guy I can't seem to get away from.
Now, Os, that's not very nice.
Maybe he just wants to be your friend.
Eh...
In any case, it's only your second day.
I'll get better.
Mom!
Can we talk about my boarded windows?!
Yeah, babe.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
You just have to take it one step at a time.
Okay!
Time to, I guess, go to school.
I guess Mom does not fucking care that, like, you know, my windows are boarded up.
Hey, Dad.
You might be a big sixth grader now, but you can't outrun a mom smooch.
Please, Mom, not in front of the animatronic.
Be good today, Oswald.
Remember that Dad and I are always here for you.
Okay.
Dad, do you want to give me a smooch too?
No?
Okay.
I wish you would believe me about Dad.
All right.
Let's go.
Sapphire, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Swing trap entering the room like a tired, tired Dad.
I mean, he still has to go to 7-Eleven.
All right.
Day three.
Everybody loves our pizza.
Especially Chica.
Ha!
Is Oswald the ocelot?
Looking for a place to molt?
Ocelot doesn't even do that, Dylan.
This is why you can't read when we're in sixth grade.
I bet you Dylan is, like, that kid that got held back three grades and he's, like, actually 17.
Like, I guess you'd be the expert.
Wait, he is.
He could...
Oh!
He's, like, taller than him too.
He's definitely held back.
He's, like, taller than Oswald.
I got way bigger problems than you today.
He's, like, 21.
Am I gonna...
Oh, what?
Oh, I'm fucking...
Did not take my meds.
What's the matter, Oswald?
Nothing, Mrs. Meechum.
I just can't focus, I guess.
Maybe you need to stretch your legs.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
To clear your mind.
I left a book behind.
I left a book behind in the principal's office.
Would you mind getting it for me?
All right, let's go.
Let's go grab the...
Let's go grab the book.
How can I save dad if I can barely even get through school?
Come on, Os.
Like mom said, one step at a time.
All right.
Let's see.
Is the VTuber kid here now?
No, because everybody's a good student and they're not walking around.
Oh, principal!
I need a book!
Can I grab a book?
Hey, what are you doing outside class?
Um, I'm getting a book for Mrs. Meechum.
No, you're not, kid.
You're helping me find the key to my...
Okay, side quest time.
Huh?
I got locked out of my office when I went to get...
When I went to oversee student behavior.
Um, I'll look around.
You're a lifesaver, little...
Oh, this is definitely a public school.
There's like...
Where's the janitor?
Why is there a spider?
Right here.
Oh, yeah.
No, 100%.
Why are there spiders walking around here?
Door is locked.
Oh, my God.
School is falling apart right now.
I think they fired the janitor.
I'm pretty sure.
Like, nothing seems to be cleaned right now.
Like...
Even the walls look fucking dirty.
Oh, there's the keys.
Wait, why are the keys here?
In this classroom.
Miss principal, what were you doing in this classroom?
Eating her snack.
I forgot.
Wait, so she like...
Wait, this pr...
Wait.
The school has like two classrooms.
Like...
I just realized the school literally has two classrooms and that's it.
This is not a very good school.
This is not.
Let's see.
Here you go, principal.
Whoa.
The school only has like...
This public school is only sixth grade.
Every grade you go...
Every grade you have to go to a new school.
Whoa.
Where did you find...
My name.
You know...
I searched almost every room in the school.
There's two rooms.
What do you mean I searched every...
We're lucky.
Exactly, Oswald.
There's two rooms.
Almost every school?
I better be off now.
I think I heard someone calling for me in the...
There's a cafeteria.
Where's the cafeteria?
It's at like the school...
The cafeteria is like at a different address.
Like it's in a different school.
So the principal has to like travel to a different school for the cafeteria.
Cafeteria?
Where?
Wait, what's this?
Dad will come for his parent here, but that thing will come to those.
You don't know that.
Wait, what is that on the table?
What if dad comes to the...
Dad...
The animatronic goes to the fucking parent-teacher conference.
You don't know that.
Finally, now I can get back to class.
What is that?
Yeah, wait, what's that?
Dad teach Dylan not to mess with me.
Wait, what the fuck did...
Oh, is that the little...
The hand thing?
What is that?
Oh, is it...
Yeah, it's the stretchy hands.
Yeah.
The cafeteria is the pizza place.
These kids are screwed.
Yeah.
There's only like a cafeteria.
The cafeteria is literally the pizza...
It's Jeff's pizza.
You certainly took your time, Oswald.
Sorry, I had like a side quest.
Sorry, Ms. Mecham.
I don't really need that...
Why lie?
Just tell them about an alibi.
It's even a good alibi.
You literally had an adult witness you.
I'll see you tomorrow, class.
Make sure you're writing your essays.
Alibi?
Like, why lie?
Literally have an alibi with the fucking principal.
All right.
YouTuber kid?
All right, we don't care.
I don't care about random conversations with you, child.
All right.
How about you?
Who are you?
Okay, I don't care.
You don't matter to me.
Where are all the other children?
But there's ants here too.
Oh, gross.
Who still has their backpack over there?
Not VTuber kid.
Not worth it.
VTuber kid?
Oh, I literally just talked to you.
No, I don't.
I don't care about you.
VTuber kid?
God damn it.
Wait, did they do okay in volleyball though?
Oh, good job.
Congratulate.
Look, it's VTuber kid and the volleyball team.
Renfield, bring your own blood.
It's such a fun game.
It's super cool.
I know how I feel about eating bugs in real life to level up though.
What about the recovering chocolate?
Oh, now we're talking.
Look, I'm very committed to the volleyball team and the school.
Look, I want to know how they did.
I just want to make sure they made it to the finals.
Bro, where the fuck is the VTuber child?
VTuber kid?
No, okay, I talked to you already.
Okay, I don't think he's.
I hope they made it to the finals.
They made it through preliminaries.
And Toki shoved it to the lockers.
No, Toki even uses these lockers.
Is... he's not in the lockers.
He's not in the lockers.
There's no way he fits in there!
Okay.
Alright, we're out.
Guys, I think I'm- I'm- I have good- I'm making good progress.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, we leave.
At least we checked.
I did!
I did check, guys.
Alright.
There's literally two rooms, guys.
There's no other room I'd be in.
There's only two rooms.
We've established that together.
Alright, night three.
Two more nights left.
Is this game longer than- Longer than two- five nights?
Like, mom!
Is this not weird, mom?
Okay.
We have to find a way to escape.
I mean, we just go down, left, down.
Alright.
Here we go.
We walk.
Whoa, shit!
Open the door!
Lily, run!
We're- we're there!
Wait, are you- What is going on?
What do you mean?
I can't open the door?
I just stopped.
I just forgot how to open doors, apparently.
I'm so sorry.
Like, I fucking lost my poseable thumbs, apparently.
Like, what the fuck happened to my arms?
Like...
I couldn't reach my hands to sway.
Like, what the fuck happened to my hands?
I literally had one job and it was door open.
Door in.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, I think this is the same.
He has to be, like, right here.
There's no way.
Alright.
Nope, he's gone.
It won't budge!
Wait, where the fuck do I go?
The attic?
Like, where do I go?
Oh, shit!
Not there, apparently.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Cat!
Do something, Cat!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
That's not fair!
That's not fair.
He never looked left.
I knew it.
I knew he'd never look left.
No one ever looks left.
No!
Go to your parents' room!
Go to see mom!
Yes!
Mom!
It worked.
I told you, they never look left.
It's always right.
Springtrap's right-handed, so they always look right.
Okay.
How?
What do I do?
I'm stuck here now.
What do I...
What do I do?
Wait.
Attic?
No stairs?
I need a ladder?
Oh.
Haha.
You didn't see me, loser.
Hahaha!
Okay, I gotta go to the attic.
It's okay, we still have time.
There's no way he's gonna go this way.
There's no way.
There's no way he's a freak if he gets there.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No, fuck this.
What do you mean I can't use that?
Okay, fuck this.
Rope time.
Oh, nice!
Easy.
Alright.
Go to the ball pit.
Yeah, I'm not dealing.
I'm gonna, like, use the ladder when it's daytime.
I'm not fucking picking up the ladder now.
Like, fuck that.
To be fair, Oswald...
To be fair, the animatronic is spending more time with me than my actual dad.
Wait, what's wrong with this area?
Weird, where are the doors?
Yeah, what happened, Jeff?
You here to pick up pizza?
No, just hanging out.
Oh.
Someone with the name I am a loser I'm a loser.
I got the place in an order.
They still haven't picked up their pizza.
I'm a loser must be new in town.
Jeff, I don't think that's a real name.
I'm a loser.
Damn.
Stay in school, kid.
Oh, damn!
But Jeff, you own a successful pizza place.
It can't be that bad.
Look!
He's here.
This town used to be really something.
Look at it now.
This is literally our only restaurant.
You can't judge this.
This is our only fucking restaurant.
Heck, look at this dump.
I'll get out of town if I can actually find any work.
Wouldn't this place be more successful if this is literally our only restaurant?
Pizza used to be a lot better.
Back in the old days.
Though I have to admit, ever since Jeff took over, it got a lot cheaper.
Quantity over quality, I guess.
Oh, no.
I bet you he reheats the pizzas.
Alright, time to go in my ball pit time machine.
Back to 1985 I go.
That thing came from the arcade last time.
Maybe it's keeping dad there.
Chip, too.
Alright, we gotta go to the arcade.
I have to go all the way to our left side.
Okay.
I'm gonna walk, cause I don't trust anybody.
I'm gonna walk.
Okay, that was close.
That was actually close.
That was pretty close.
The timing for that was actually crazy.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha
Arrrr...
It's no use!
Nooooooo!
I have to go the other wayee!
Arrrr... Arrrr...
Arrrr... Arrrr... Arrrr...
Okay,
the arcade should be here.
Please.
Woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah.
Wasn't that- was that door vibrating?
There's no way it looked under.
That's fucking right little bitch.
You're not gonna look under here.
That's fucking right.
Run!
Go back to your 7-lemon job.
Scared horrors.
Kayo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I was like, I don't think doors were supposed to vibrate unless there's a fucking sick rave going on right now.
I don't think it was a rave.
Okay, maybe here then?
Go to the arcade here?
Wait, how do I go then?
What?
The door is shut.
Wait, what?
This is literally the only other way!
The vent?
Does the vent head over there?
I thought the vent- there's only two ways in the vent.
Which is here and the other area.
Yeah!
Is there another vent?
Oh fuck, there's another vent?
Okay, we gotta figure out where the other vent is.
Cause I don't remember.
I don't remember the other vent.
There was a vent in the- oh my god, I fucking- There was a vent in the entrance.
Oh, oh, oh, there's no way he saw me, right?
Or, or, or, or, or...
No!
God fucking damn it.
God damn- that's good, that's good, it reset.
I need it to reset.
I need it to re- I thought I could flash the flashlight!
I thought I was fast enough!
Okay, oh wait, I haven't traveled yet.
Time travel time.
Okay.
Alright, here I go.
Back in it I go.
God damn it.
I hate it when he fucking stream snipes me.
Okay.
Alright, if I- is- I wonder if it'll be like the same code.
Where he'll just be at that door.
No?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, where did I hear him?
Oh, it's vibrating.
I hear two things.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, he's just gonna walk away.
And then we have a vent.
Scared, scared horror noises.
Wait, Chica?
God fucking.
Fuck am I gonna tell Chica?
God.
Okay.
Okay, I have an idea.
We turn on the radio and then we run.
Oh, no.
No!
Nani Chica don't go to the right.
Okay.
And I hear a spring trap to my right still.
He's like gurgling right now.
Oh, God damn it.
This is not fair.
Okay.
Okay, Chica has to come back.
Chica, you gotta get out.
There's no pizza there, Chica.
There's no pizza there.
Chica.
I can wait all day.
Vibrate.
Vibrate door.
Oh, my God.
That is actually so unlucky.
They're both like...
Both here.
Wait, does that mean like...
The others are gonna come out too?
Okay.
No, I hear spring trap to my right.
Chica, what the fuck?
Leave!
Why are you...
Why are you still there, Chica?
Where else would she go?
That's the thing.
Where else would Chica go?
Nani?
No, you fucking can't even...
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know, please don't go there.
No, what the fuck?
What are you doing?
Are you fucking kidding me?
No!
Please!
My God.
He's gonna say...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Why would you close that?
I don't know.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be like, how am I that unlucky?
Oh my god, I'm that unlucky.
Okay, he didn't go... he didn't go left.
Oh, he didn't go left.
Okay.
Okay, I heard the door.
I heard the door.
That's so fucked.
That's actually so fucked, man.
Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor.
Hoor, hoor.
Hoor, hoor, hoor.
Okay, up we go.
Alright.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, then that should be the arcade.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's the arcade right here.
Oh, there's a photo.
That's my school picture.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's my school picture.
Are you... how is it still locked?
How is... how is it still locked?
Oh my god, please, please.
Oh yeah.
How is it still locked?
How do I get in?
Okay.
There's no way.
Is there another vent?
How many vents are in this fucking place?
Okay.
Leave.
That's where I was!
I'm so fucking confused.
Okay, party.
There's really no way!
Okay.
I go there.
That's the storage.
How... they blocked everything!
Is there another vent?
They... they blocked everything!
Okay.
Is he gonna open the door?
Wait!
Wait, he opened the door!
Did he open the door?
Oh, he has keys.
That's so fucked.
That's...
That's cheating!
That's fucking cheating!
What are you doing?
Leave!
Chica, please!
Leave me alone!
I don't have my key!
Okay.
There has to be...
There's no vent to it!
Like...
There's that vent up top!
What?
Can I make it?
Can I make it up there?
The gifts?
No, it...
Oh my God, no!
I can't!
It won't let me!
Okay, then maybe here?
The door is...
What isn't locked?
What the fuck is...
What the fuck is not locked?
Oh my God!
Everything is locked.
Maybe it's the party room.
Maybe...
Maybe you...
Maybe the party room.
I know.
It's the party room.
It's time to party.
No, we can't...
It's locked.
It's also locked, guys.
Everything is locked.
Because fuck me, I guess.
Are you fucking...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
There's no way.
Chica is just an alarm.
She's just an alarm.
All right, here we go.
Bye, Chica.
Wait, where's Springtrap?
Oh, there he is.
What you gonna do?
Find me?
Idiot.
Okay, now that I know.
Chica is just an alarm.
Like, she can't do jack shit.
So I'm safe.
Okay.
All right.
We go to the...
We go to the party room.
There has to be something at the party room.
What are...
What are they hiding in the party?
They're hide...
It's...
They're hiding a locked room.
Okay, now that we know that they're hiding a fucking locked room.
And this one's also locked.
But that's okay.
That's...
That's okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything is locked.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Yes.
That's the key.
There's no way he's in there.
There's no way.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
There's the key.
Oh, god.
There it is.
Oh, my God.
There it was.
There it is.
.
I can play some videos.
We're playing video games now.
Shop the puzzle!
Ooh, okay.
How do I do this?
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, this is...
This should be easy, right?
Okay, this...
This...
Okay.
Sir, am I timed?
Okay, no, okay.
Do I win anything for solving it?
Do I win anything, guys, if I solve this puzzle?
Okay, but, like, what if I do this, and then I put this here, and then I just need to put him here.
Oh, no.
What do I get with tickets?
Chat, what do I get with tickets?
Okay, but what if I put this here, and then put this here, and then this here, and then and then this here, and then, um...
Do I get anything?
What kind of prizes do I get?
Chat.
Satisfaction?
Okay, but what kind of prizes do I get?
No, no, no, I'm not going in circles.
I know what I'm doing.
Guys, I know what I'm doing.
It works.
Guys, trust, trust, trust.
See?
And then I do this, and then I do...
What is this?
What the fuck is this part of the body?
Is it this?
Oh, I did it!
Yeah!
I told you!
Trust the process!
Nice.
Okay, I'm not screenshotting.
New music!
Oh, okay.
Looks like I got some tickets!
Okay, we don't need tickets, actually.
What the fuck?
Hello?
Bonnie?
Hello, Bonnie.
Are you a good guy?
Guys, I don't think... I don't think that's a good guy.
Maybe if I know more about that thing, I can somehow lure it away.
Okay, guys, we gotta get in here and read.
We gotta start reading.
We're not like Dylan.
We know how to read.
Why do I just get... I did it!
Okay.
Um... Hey, that's me!
Okay, where's the...
Where's the sketchbook?
Okay, there it is.
What... What was it?
Where's Bonnie?
Wait.
Did they... Did he never sketch anything about Bonnie?
It's just Freddy, Chica... Oh, there it is.
Bonnie.
Adjust... Do not attempt to play.
Any voice malfunction must be reported.
Oh!
Okay, we just gotta play the guitar.
Um... Breaks at least one soap.
Change them.
Upper manager requested all strings to be dumped off-site due to... Tech 2 was asked to dump them at the mill.
Oh!
Okay, we just gotta find the string.
Okay.
I'll get it.
We gotta get the guitar.
Okay.
I know how to do this.
I figured it out.
Boom.
And then...
And I just gotta... I just gotta fix... I just gotta bring future guitar strings to...
Uh... Present guitar strings to past guitar.
And then... And then Canada will become America's state.
After I bring it...
Canada become...
Alaska... We might have lost Alaska, but we gained Canada.
The fuck?
Oh, shit.
I think I'm dead.
Whoa!
It's okay.
There's no way I'll trip, right?
That's fucking right.
Goodbye, bitch.
Alright.
Okay, I need to go to the mill and see if I can... If there's... Wait.
Did I already got strings?
I just... I keep dumpster diving, so I can't tell.
Alright.
I don't think so.
Okay, I'm gonna see if the mill... If I can, like, activate it now.
If I can go to the mill.
Alright.
I've seen the prices in Canada.
It's cause we have paper money!
Okay?
The only way to solve this is if we can use American currency.
1985 mill?
Am I allowed to go out?
Like...
I don't even know if I'm allowed to go out in, like, uh...
1985!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
You keep losing.
Try not to get... Oh, thank you for the amazing tip.
Oh, man.
I wish I knew that, too.
Wait.
No.
There's nothing in the garbage.
Yuck.
Pretty certain this trash has been sitting here since the mill.
Wait.
Can I actually go out now?
Is that actually possible?
Alright.
Let's find out.
You keep losing.
Try sucking less.
Thank you, game.
I really appreciate that.
I don't understand.
Can I actually go...
Okay.
I'm gonna try touching the guitar and see if that works.
I'm gonna touch the guitar and then, like...
Oh, no.
I don't wanna go there.
Yeah, but, like, where's the...
There was no string at the mill.
Did I actually...
Did I actually, like, not...
Was that actually a string?
Dude, nothing showed up.
Wait.
Nothing showed up on...
Nothing highlighted.
Okay.
Let me try again.
Nothing highlighted at all.
So, like, I couldn't tell.
Alright.
Let's try again.
Let's try.
Are you sure?
No.
I can't get one guide.
It was, like, three guides.
At best, it was three guides.
Okay.
Maybe I have to...
Yeah.
Maybe I have to touch the guitar.
No!
I don't want to fucking leave!
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that the string?
I can't... Yeah.
I can't touch it.
It won't let me touch it.
Alright.
I think I have to touch the guitar.
And it'll let me activate it.
This is the longest third night of my life.
Also, wouldn't mom think it's weird that I'm not in my room?
Like, don't parents be, like, check up on you to be like, Alright, sweetie.
Goodnight.
Here's a goodnight kiss.
And she'll be like, Where's my son?
And also, why is the windows boarded up?
Does she not check my room?
Does she not check, like, how I'm doing?
Oh, yeah, she's at work.
Yeah, but when she comes back home from work, she'd be like, where the fuck is my son?
Hot tub time machine.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, I touched it.
Oh, wait!
There's no guitar here!
Wait, where did the guitar go?
Oh, shit!
There it is!
Someone...
Okay, it's time!
I figured it out!
Alright.
Okay, and then we go...
Now we go back!
Time to go back to the...
Time to go back in there.
Alright.
Then we go to the mill.
We don't need coins.
We don't need prizes.
Guys.
We figured out that the prizes are literally just music and lock.
Like, am I really gonna listen to the fucking music?
Like...
Let's go back.
I actually really am enjoying this game so far.
It's, like, different from what I usually play.
But I really...
I think it... I now understand what people say.
This has been one of the better FNAF games.
Alright.
Here we go.
I have no idea what's going on with the lore.
Just that, like, where the fuck is going on with Dad.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, stream time.
Oh!
Where the fuck is he?
Oh no, now he's doing No I'm Poor.
Who knew Oswald... Oswald the Oswald was also Oswald the Vacoon.
This will definitely...
They already know I'm poor!
You're poor too, Dylan!
You go to the same public school as I do!
Joke's on you, Dylan!
We're all poor here!
Dylan, why are you here?
Yeah, what's he doing here?
Dylan!
I can't worry about him right now.
I need to get back.
Yeah, he was here too!
He is also as poor as me!
It was an indie game and Scott was like, wait, this is better than all my other FNAF games.
I'm gonna buy them.
And now it's not an indie game.
Because Scott bought them.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
I gotta fix the guitar.
And then play it.
And then after playing it, we gotta...
Okay, we gotta go back to the fucking arcade.
And free Chip.
Alright, hot tub time machine.
Let's go!
What if I just bring another...
What if I just bring Jeff with me?
I'll be like, Jeff, jump in!
Jump in, Jeff!
Why don't I just do that?
Yeah, alright.
Alright.
Okay.
Plug it in!
Okay, freaks.
Let's jam!
Alright.
Uh-oh, I need to get out of here!
Oh, this way?
He's like, who touched my guitar?
Who touched it?
Who the fuck touched my guitar?
Oh, hey, Freddy.
Oh, I can get through here now!
Nobody touches my guitar.
Bro, I fixed your guitar.
Oh, oh, oh!
How to follow the vents!
Cool animatronic monster!
Anyway, here's Wonderwall!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Holy shit!
Okay, that was scary.
That was actually scary.
Okay, it's this way.
And then...
There you are!
Oh, oh no, he has brain damage.
There's no way.
That's a strong mallet.
Are you okay?
What's 2 plus 2, Chip?
Thanks.
I don't know what that...
Thank me later.
Was there a grown-up with you?
No, have you...
Oh yeah, Mike left you to die!
By the way, you guys have been friends for like...
six years!
Mike left you to...
fucking die!
I found him.
He's safe now.
And you met me for 15 minutes.
I saved your ass.
You're gonna be an adult...
when I go back to the present.
Remember me.
Come on, man.
We gotta split!
No, I...
Where am I going?
Oh shit, Freddy!
Freddy and Bonnie at once?
Hey, Freddy!
Bye, Freddy!
Right here, I'll go.
Oh, I can't sneak out.
Okay, spiders.
That's good, that's good.
Spiders are not as...
not bad.
Spiders are pretty easy.
It's just typing up the dead.
It's a type racer.
Goodbye!
Oh, I can literally just leave.
Alright.
Guess I'll just go here.
I like how Freddy's just stands there menacingly.
Like...
He doesn't do shit!
He's just like, hey guys!
Hey guys!
I heard everybody is having a good time!
Ah!
I'm not having a good time!
Wait, what?
Whoa, what the fuck was that?
In fact, she was not having a good time.
I know I heard his voice.
Hang in there, Dad.
Until you touch my guitar.
Oh shit, you're right!
Maybe I had a higher budget!
Maybe 911 will work in the past!
You're right!
Oh my god.
After school, no idea how I'll make it through that day.
I barely slept.
Alright.
Oh, I should pet the cat!
I knew that she was not having a good day.
Hello!
Plus five for petting cat.
Mom?
Where's mom?
Wouldn't mom make me lunch?
Mom?
Where's mom?
Oh shit!
Wait!
Wait, I'm gonna check the attic.
No!
Attic!
I could've moved the ladder.
No!
Okay, time for school.
God damn it, fucking education time!
God damn it!
It's education time!
Alright.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
Hello, kids?
Oh, nobody wants to talk to me?
It's okay, I have zero friends apparently.
Hello?
Hey Dylan!
Hey look, it's Oswald the raccoon.
I'm surprised he's still not out.
We're all poor!
Where are you fuckers?
Yeah, he probably smells right at home there.
Whoa!
They look like they're funking it right now.
Oh no, I definitely did not take my meds.
Oh, look at Freddy go!
Oh my god, he's doing the robot!
Okay, wait, Bonnie's humping the Okay, not gonna lie, like, they got some moves.
Bro, okay, Freddy's got some moves.
Like, look at him go!
Like, get it, Freddy!
Bonnie is...
Bonnie!
This is a peak...
This is an elementary school, Bonnie.
This is...
Damn me.
This is the Olympic breakdancing.
Maybe all that trash has made him sick.
Maybe he's finally losing it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ho ho ho!
Ho ho ho ho!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
I gotta get outta here!
Oh god, I gotta go to the pop-it!
Okay!
Gotta go outta here!
Gotta go to the pop-it!
Okay, but what if I go home instead?
Can I...
Like, do I...
Do I...
Isn't there a kid that's been waiting for me at the library for, like, 20 years?
Like, I feel like I've been...
Oh, hey there!
Hey, kid!
I'm fire...
Hey, firecracker kid!
Oh, she's still there!
You still wanna trade for one?
Yeah, I have this.
Wait, what am I supposed to be trading with him?
Like, tickets?
What does he want?
Like, what does firecracker kid even want?
Do you want my tickets?
The gun!
I feel like I don't need firecrackers anyway.
Nah, I'm gonna keep it.
I don't need firecrackers.
Alright.
I'm gonna go to the pizzeria.
The gun!
No, you're not fucking taking my gun!
Alright.
Back in.
There we go.
I don't think I can go back.
Oh, where's Jeff?
Jeff?
Wait, where is Jeff?
Oh, there's Jeff!
Hey, kid.
Shouldn't you be in school?
Um, not today.
Hmm.
Okay.
You know where to find me.
Let's see.
Now's my chance to get a head start.
Oh, yeah.
Wouldn't it be daytime by then?
Oh, I do need it?
Wait, okay.
Okay, guys.
I'm going back to the kid.
Wait, isn't he supposed to be at school?
Wait a minute!
That kid's supposed to be in school too!
Like...
I just realized!
Wait, he's looking ditchy school!
Okay, he's just like in the firecracker kit.
Don't care.
He's too cool.
He's too cool!
Oh, I can't.
Oh, I was gonna say can I not leave?
Alright.
Okay.
What does he want?
Guys, what can I trade for him?
You want this?
That's not cool enough.
Give me something a little more retro.
What the?
This?
That's not cool enough.
Give me something a little more retro.
What the fuck?
I have a gun?
Oh.
That's not cool.
I have a gun.
What the fuck?
A gun is not cool enough, guys.
Oh, retro.
Oh my god.
What do you...
I got a ticket counter.
Is that about your validator?
What's cool enough?
What?
I'm not cool enough for him.
Okay.
Apparently, apparently I'm not cool enough for him.
He keeps telling me I'm not cool enough.
Alright.
Apparently.
Maybe, maybe I can trade something here.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Everything is broken.
Yeah.
Wait.
Unless...
Can I use any of this?
Electron gun?
I can't use that.
I can't use anything!
What's the point?
Wait.
Maybe?
I don't have the right...
What would this... What would this need?
Wolf power?
What would you need?
Wooden balls?
It says I have the item.
What would the item be?
Oh, shit!
What did I do?
Oh!
Well, I watched Dad repair so many random things over the... Oh, I did it!
What is this?
What game is this?
Oh, guys!
I gotta get... I'm so swollen, Freddy!
Oh, God!
I gotta do my reps!
Am I swollen enough?
Yay!
Why is that bear so swollen?
Yippee!
This is enough for a voucher.
Guys, I'm so swollen now!
Yay!
Hahaha!
Okay, it has to be one of these items.
What do I can exchange for, then?
Alright, what's this?
Shoot the balloons.
Oh!
It's like space... Wait, what is it called?
Um... Oh, my... Oh!
Did I win?
Oh, I didn't win.
It's like asteroids?
Oh, my God!
That's so retro!
That's so fucking retro!
Oh, my God!
Oh, God!
Oh...
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, we're okay.
What's the high score?
What score do I need to get?
Do I just need to destroy all of it?
Okay.
It's asteroid.
Alright.
Come on.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, no!
Please!
Do I get tickets now?
Please, no!
It has to be ticket.
I did so much!
What?
Oh!
Oh, I got tickets!
Okay.
Okay, it says I got tickets.
Okay, that...
That's good.
I got two tickets from that.
Alright, this is like skee-ba.
We don't care about skee-ba.
Wait, can I do this, then?
Ticket counter?
Can I get prizes?
Uh...
No?
Puzzle?
Control panel?
Oh!
Oh, I have enough for a prize voucher!
But like, where do I get my prizes?
Where?
Here?
Oh, shit.
Uh...
Can I use that here?
Oh, here!
Can I get the, the, the, the firecracker now?
I'm very...
Why would... You want some...
Yes!
Oh, my God!
Finally!
I have something that's retro!
I finally did it!
Oh, my God!
Good!
I got it!
Got the retro!
Let's go!
Oh, my God!
Finally!
I've got the firecrackers!
I got a Game Boy!
Oh, my God!
Thank God!
Alright.
I got the thing.
I got the cool thing.
Oh, nice!
You got yourself a trade!
Awesome!
Thanks!
Pleasure doing business with ya!
Nice.
Okay.
I have no idea, like, what to do with the, uh...
What to do with the, uh...
The firecrackers.
But you guys said we needed it.
I can't believe you wouldn't take the gun!
I'm so cool now.
I'm so fucking cool.
He thinks I'm cool now.
Now I have a better reputation.
I literally fixed his arcade machines for free.
And then, like, uh, made him up his power bill by, like, 50%.
He won't notice, right?
He's not gonna notice the power bill went up.
Toki, you got robbed!
I could've sold that on eBay!
It's retro!
I could've got so much money!
Huh?
Night 4.
Wait, it's night time?
You gotta be kidding me.
How many kids did...
Wait, they tried more?
I freed Chip and Mike!
Alright, it's time.
The cops must work here.
Okay.
9-1-1.
There's no way the budget's worse down here.
Unfortunately... What?
Still?
I'm in 1985!
How is this still?
It's 1985!
Okay, but where do I have to...
Oh.
That was close.
Where do I have to go?
Yeah, what if I call my mom in the past?
Right.
Okay, guys.
What's my mom's phone number again?
Whoops, not that.
What was it?
I forgot.
I forgot my mom's phone number.
555 something something something.
555.
Oh, my contacts!
You're right!
I don't need... I don't need backseating.
Mom?
Oswald?
Is everything alright, honey?
Yeah.
Just...
Has dad been acting weird to you?
He's been a bit quiet.
But that's just work stress.
Don't worry, Oswald.
He's okay.
How do I get reception in 1985?
Guys, I don't think I was meant to make that call in 1985.
1985.
Okay, I have no idea where I'm supposed to go.
Where's the child?
Oh, hey.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Not here.
Oh!
The call of 85.
Oh, why are you back here?
Hello?
Back in the bed I go.
They don't know.
They knew.
I thought I could go somewhere else.
I thought I could go.
But you fucking snitch.
You fucking...
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh my god, dude.
Fuck Chica.
That bitch.
Where's that other scream?
I have no idea where the other scream is.
Is it the security room?
Where is the other scream coming from, chat?
I have no idea.
Uh...
God damn it.
Chica's a snitch.
She's a fucking snitch.
Whoa.
Is there a battery?
Imagine.
Oh, here!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Not here.
Is this the security room?
I don't think I've been to the security.
Yeah.
You fucking...
bitch.
I don't remember what the game was for this.
I don't remember what the...
what the minigame was for this one.
Oh.
It took her fucking forever to find me.
Please, go anywhere but here.
Oh.
Chica, you whore.
Chica, you fucking whore.
No!
Why are you at the fucking security?
That's literally the one thing I had to go.
I had to go there.
Oh my god.
Leave!
Chica!
You bitch!
Leave!
Oh my god!
You need to fucking...
I gave you pizza!
You whore, whore, whore.
Whore, whore.
Whore, whore, whore.
Oh!
That's fucking right.
Get fire crackered!
There's another child here?
Hello, child.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like that.
Okay.
Oh, there's the phone.
I can't imagine that you...
I don't know.
I'm worried.
I'm worried, phone guy.
If you really have...
No, that's okay.
I don't want to do that.
That's okay.
Who are you?
I've never seen you before.
Oh, hey.
That's dad's wedding ring.
Oh, batteries!
I need that.
Here.
They're close.
What?
Who?
The cameras.
What?
Alright.
Okay.
Looking at the cameras.
None of the cameras work.
Oh, shit!
Oh.
Follow me.
We have to get out of here.
They're still out there.
I need to get them away from here.
I probably shouldn't call attention to myself.
Do I leave?
What do I do?
What?
Why do I...
There's nobody here?
They wouldn't let me press the big red button.
Is it radio time?
Maybe.
Okay.
I'm gonna do the radio.
It's radio time.
It's time to dance.
It's time to dance, everybody.
Oh, I don't like that.
Hey, let me look into here.
Surely.
Surely nothing bad will happen if I do that.
Maybe.
Time to dance, everybody.
It's time to dance.
It's time to dance, everybody.
Okay.
That should work.
Thank God I hoarded all my batteries.
Thank God.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Balloon Boy.
No, where did she go?
What the fuck?
Where is she?
That's Big Spider.
I didn't know there was fucking spider animatronics, too.
Oh.
Where is he taking her?
What?
Where did he take her?
Yeah.
Look for the child.
Child!
Where the fuck did he take the child?
Child?
Child, are you here?
Child, I thought you were scared!
You liar!
You fucking liar!
You told me you were scared!
And then you fucking follow a stranger?
Pick a struggle!
Pick a lane!
I know she's in here.
She has to be in the freezer.
I bet I can find something to smash it.
I need to get that girl out there before she freezes.
I need to get something to smash it?
Oh no, please stop crying.
Please, you're only making me more...
No, I didn't realize that was noise!
The hammer!
There's a hammer?
When did I have a hammer?
Goodbye.
Where's the fucking hammer?
Oh!
The arcade!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Don't worry, I always knew where the hammer was.
Don't worry, guys.
I always knew where it was.
Chat.
Okay, it's like this way.
Okay.
Oh.
A spooky...
Please stop crying!
You did this!
You literally held...
Oh!
What does... What does that do?
Like, what... What does... He just said, hey.
What did he...
Oh, that's the phone.
That I'm not gonna take.
Like, what... What the...
Oh hey, no, there is a phone here.
Hello?
What
the fuck are you talking about?
I don't even know what I'm looking at.
I mean, look at the sketchbook.
I was gonna eat this cupcake.
Oh, he blocks the door.
Okay, I was gonna just be like, what are you doing, Freddy?
What are...
All right,
phone guy.
All right, whatever you say.
She's over there.
Leave.
No, she's getting closer.
Come on!
I just wanna grab the hat.
Fucking freak.
Oh, that was close.
That was pretty close.
That was like one second.
Oh, that was one second.
I'm gonna walk.
And then I'm gonna...
Yoink.
Come on now.
What am I saying?
I just bashed the head.
Why can't I just like swing the hammer at the fucking animatronics?
To be fair, I'm a child, so I don't think that's gonna cause much damage.
Now that I think about it.
Fucking freak.
Okay.
Oh God, please.
I don't wanna do this all over again, please.
Oh...
No!
Don't trip!
Closet!
I thought that was the closet!
No!
I legit thought that was...
I fucking hate you!
I hate you, child!
I hate you all over again!
You fucking stupid bitch!
You fucking...
Oh my God.
That bitch!
She's the one that fucking followed the goddamn animatronic too!
Okay.
God, why do I have to save her?
I should be able to pick and choose who I wanna save.
I don't wanna save her.
I hate her.
Out of all the children.
Out of all the kids in this stupid pizzeria.
She's the one that deserves to die.
Oh my God.
I like how...
I don't question the giant fucking spider, I guess.
Am I okay?
I am not okay.
I have to do this all over again.
I have to do this fucking shit all over again.
Again, I'm not okay.
I thought...
Okay, that's fine.
Just let me through.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, let me... I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna go here.
I'm gonna go into my time machine.
You can't catch me if I'm in my time machine!
I...
I'm so sad.
I wish it saves here.
The fact that it doesn't save here is the worst part.
I think that's the worst part.
It doesn't save here.
Are you... Bro!
What the fuck, bro!
Fuck you!
Actually, fuck you.
You fucking camper.
Okay.
Back at it we go.
There's no way he's there twice, right?
There's no way.
It better reset twice, right?
I hear him.
He's like far to the left.
Okay.
Alright.
And then I'm gonna bump into Chica.
Get away from me, you fucking bitch.
I see your hand, Bonnie.
I see your fucking hand.
This game is supposed to be three hours long.
Okay.
Why does it honk?
It's fucking cardboard!
Where is he?
Go right.
Oh, that was close.
That was... I didn't know... It's cardboard!
Cardboard doesn't go boop!
What kind of cardboard is that?
Oh, God.
I heard something to my right.
Okay.
This is gonna be rough.
I'm just gonna hide in here.
I'm gonna hide in here until Springtrap appears.
I'm gonna... I can't... I can't...
I hear him.
Where is he coming from?
Where...
I hear him.
I hear his little fucking... big-ass paws!
Leave.
Please leave!
Okay.
I don't wanna run.
He's literally outside the door.
He's literally outside.
They have things I do for this child.
For this stupid kid.
Okay.
Get out.
Get out of here.
Oh.
Get out.
Got it.
Child.
Are you dead?
God fucking dammit!
I knew I should've just left her!
Oh.
Okay.
You're alive.
Nevermind.
I saved the day.
Yeah.
You say?
You literally followed the animatronic, you fucker!
You bitch!
Run to the exit before...
Oh.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Oh!
No!
He grabbed me!
Get out!
Get away!
No.
I swear the fucking God get me out of here!
Get me the fuck out of here!
Get me out of here.
Hot tub time machine!
Let's go!
Okay.
This keeps getting worse and worse.
This ends tomorrow!
It's into the pit, not run out of the pit.
Debbie, thank you for the super chat.
You're in too deep, kid!
Guys, I think... I think I fucked up, guys.
Where's the chili?
Is that ketchup?
Because it came from a pizzeria?
Oh, no!
Did I sleep all day?
I'm running out of time!
No more school, no more distractions, I'm bringing Dad home!
Oh, no.
I lived the hardest part.
I fucked up.
The last day, I have to move the ladder.
On the last day, I have to move the fucking ladder.
I have to move the fucking ladder.
No!
Wait, where's the ladder go?
Wait a minute.
Wait, where did the ladder go?
Wait, can I just leave the front door?
Wait, where's the ladder?
Where is it?
Where's the ladder?
Where's the cat?
No, the cat's at the fridge.
It's night time, guys.
The cat's at the fridge.
It's night time.
Wait, is Dad not here?
Wait, where is Dad?
What is all that sound?
Where is... wait, it's daytime!
Wait, you're right!
Wait...
Oh, 555-5333.
Oh, hey, I could call Jess Pizza.
Cat?
Where's the cat?
Where did the cat go?
Cat?
Wait, cat gone.
Wait, what happened to cat?
I remembered when I was happy like that photo.
Okay, time to go to the ball pit again.
How is there still children there?
How?
Pizzeria.
Day 5.
Oh, Freddy's Pizza.
When I go in there, I'm not sure if I'll come back out.
But I guess I'm as ready as I'll ever be.
All right, here I go.
Here I go.
Okay.
It's me, Mario.
It's a me.
Hello?
Jeff?
Jeff, where did you go?
Oh, oh, there's people here.
Oh, okay.
Fuck me.
He doesn't want to talk to me.
Jeff?
Where did Jeff go?
No, no more.
But I want to know where did Jeff...
Oh, no.
What about Foxy?
It's night five and there's no Foxy.
I don't like that.
Where did Jeff go?
Jeff?
Jeff, where are you, Jeff?
I don't know where you are.
Jeff?
Are you in the security?
Oh!
Okay, Jeff.
You not get internet here?
What the fuck?
What you doing there, Jeff?
What's it look like, kid?
I'm working.
You barge in here to ask about the room of the ball pit?
No, I'm not opening the door.
Huh?
What are you talking about?
Had to start locking a door because some hooligans kept sneaking in and leaving those balls all over the place.
Bro, Jeff's gaming.
Bro, look at him go.
Holy shit, he's so fast.
Look at him go.
His fucking...
Oh, my God.
What is his finger speed?
Look at him go.
His APM, bro.
You wouldn't happen to know anything about that, would you?
No.
I mean, no.
I have no idea.
He's winning.
Do I...
You need to get into the...
I mean, I left my jacket in the room with the ball pit the other day.
Can you let me in there?
Nice try, kid.
You're wearing the exact same jacket you wore when you went in.
No, I'm not.
This is my backup jacket.
We're in a video game, so I wear the same clothes every day.
The other one has my wallet.
I kind of need to buy pizza.
Oh, yeah.
That's pretty important.
Here, take the key.
But don't go play around that ball pit anymore.
I promise I'll stay out there as soon as I'm done.
Never want to see that thing again anyway.
That gross, huh?
You have no idea.
All right, nice.
Actually, I just wanted to visit Jeff.
I didn't realize that was part of the mission, you know, to...
Wait, what the...
Jeff, do you not see this?
Jeff!
Oh, shit.
This is the kitchen.
I lost track of my...
Oh, shit.
Jeff, I fucked up.
I forgot where I was.
Oh, shit.
I didn't know where I was.
I thought that was...
I was going to bring in the Jeff.
Whoa!
Okay.
Fine, dad.
Like, ow!
What do you mean fine, dad?
Where have I not gone?
What the fuck do you...
Ugh.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Please don't open.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I guess the party room.
It has to be the party room.
I haven't gone to the party room yet.
Okay.
He has to go, right?
Goodbye.
Goodbye, dad.
Okay.
Other dad is gone.
Other dad is now gone.
Oh wait, I hear him.
Let me out of here, you stupid rabbit.
Hey, are you... there's another child?
How many kids are there?
He was locked in here by some stupid rabbit.
Strange rabbit.
What the fuck?
How come the rabbit kills everybody?
Like, kills me, but he doesn't kill this girl.
It looks like the door... what kind of party room is that?
What?
There's a key I need to get?
Where the fuck is the other key?
Okay.
Party room.
A key card.
Where the fuck is the key card?
I've been to... is it security?
It should be the security, right?
Like, I've been to everywhere, but...
I guess it should be in the security because it's a key card.
Yeah.
It's security.
That's where security goes.
Alright, Chica was here.
So, let's see.
Oh, I don't like this.
Are you... I hate you.
I fucking hate you.
I fucking hate you, Chica.
You bitch.
You fucking bitch.
Please, I just... you snitch.
Fucking stitches get stitches.
Oh,
my God.
I fucking hate her.
Okay.
The only place... unless it's in the freezer.
Do you think there's a key card?
No, the freezer is not an actual place.
Apparently.
Oh, hey, coin.
Okay.
Are you fucking...
Oh, my... there's no...
Oh, I did not want to...
Oh, okay.
Hey, did you want to look at the camera?
Oh, I'm trapped.
Yeah.
Yippee.
Like, where could it be?
Oh, they...
Okay, they put that back.
Where could the card be?
I think Chica hates me.
Oh, no.
Fuck you two.
What the fuck?
They blocked?
Okay.
Well, at least Bonnie and Freddy aren't going to do anything to me.
Is it in the oven?
There's no way.
Okay.
Yeah.
You guys are... I got one guide.
Okay.
I got it.
We got to go to...
We got to go to the basement.
If they're blocking the basement, then it has to be in the basement.
Because why would they...
I didn't fucking know.
I didn't think he'd be there.
How is that supposed to do?
He's going to come over me.
Oh, okay.
I think I got in time.
All right.
There we go.
I thought I could Metal Gear.
I thought I could Metal Gear that shit.
I fucking know.
Okay.
Bye, spiders.
All right.
Okay.
We have to go to the basement.
And I got sneak there.
I go here.
And then...
God, I'm going to hear this phone ring forever.
And I go here.
And then...
Oh, fuck this.
What's the worst that's going to happen?
Wouldn't it be funny if the worst did happen there?
Okay.
Hey, there's something here.
Token.
Okay.
There has to be something here.
Like they're guarding something.
Where did all these things come from?
What?
The animatronic?
It looks like there's something shoved into one of them.
That has to be the key card.
Yes.
Okay.
We did it.
Come on.
Okay.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh, okay.
Me trying to find the key card.
That's the one.
It's not first slot.
That's the worst that could happen.
Thank you.
I thought I was done for.
Before you get out of here, I'm looking for my dad.
Have you seen him?
No, I haven't seen anyone else.
I've been hearing weird noises coming from the vent here.
I definitely heard a man mumbling and snoring.
Wait, who's feeding him?
It's been five nights and day.
I think you're clear to run straight to the exit.
Just be careful.
Okay, good luck.
Yeah, why does every fucking animatronic trying to kill me?
But then they let these guys live.
Other than the guy would bring damage with the hammer hitting him in the head.
There's a photo.
Where the fuck's the photo?
Okay.
That was not the photo.
Dad!
Wait a minute.
Who's over here?
Great.
That bear is out there.
Hello,
Dad.
Wait, inspect my items?
Why?
What's in my items?
The saddest, most utter...
Okay, family photo.
Dad took a picture of me and my mom.
Now mom puts up with us sometimes.
Aww.
That's why...
When her dad's retro shop got a new robot, dad promised...
Aww.
Didn't have money.
Somebody bought it.
Turns out dad was the one who bought it.
He worked overtime every day for weeks just so he could surprise me.
I was so happy.
Now Springtrap has to work overtime.
Mom and dad have been great to each other since they were kids.
They always go through their wedding photo album on the day of their van anniversary.
I can't even imagine what it'd be like for mom to suddenly lose dad.
Aww.
Wait, that's sad.
Alright, goodbye, dad.
Oh, I can't leave.
Okay, I guess.
Hello?
Hello, dad?
Dad?
Sounds like something is trying to get in.
I better hide.
Okay.
Why did my frame drop after looking at my inventory?
What
did my frame drop after?
Did I fucking get a bug?
Why did my frames drop?
I didn't mean that.
What the f- Wait, what the f- My inventory and my frame started dropping.
Oh shit, not the ice cream machine.
Do we have to chase after them?
What if he's just here?
Okay, how the fuck do I fix this?
Is it the ring?
It has to be the ring.
Where's the last photo?
Wait, there's apparently another photo?
Oh my god, what happened?
It's okay.
It's not timed or anything, guys.
In the Golden Freddy room, I have plenty of time.
I have plenty of time, guys.
He's not gonna chase- Oh god!
That fucking race!
I literally looked at one item and then my fucking- My fucking frames dropped like hell.
This is actually crazy.
Just save that first.
No.
Going in and out of- Okay, let's go in and out of those.
That's actually funny.
I literally, like, looked at my inventory and then my frames fucking dropped.
Like, what happened?
Like, actually- I just wanted to- Oh my god.
What happened to my frames?
Jesus.
I can't- I didn't fix it!
Where's the last photo?
Wait, where is it?
Guys, tell me there's one more photo.
Where is it?
No, saving it.
No!
Wait, is that it?
No, that's not a photo.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh my god, it's in the dining hall.
Where's the last photo?
They're not in- I got everything!
Oh, you need to complete- Bottom the most photos I've seen.
Where is it?
Where's the fucking last photo?
Yeah.
Okay.
Bottom right in the- wait, it is?
Oh no, in the Golden Freddy room.
Okay.
Oh god.
It's okay, nothing can kill me now.
Nothing can kill me.
I have it?
Wait, there's nothing here, you fucking lie!
Oh hey, there you go, here's dad's name tag.
I did it!
Yay!
I got all five!
Where's the name tag?
Dad looks so sad when he told me he lost his job at the mall.
I don't understand why he kept saying it.
I'm sorry, I've never thought it was his fault.
Dad always works so hard.
I'm glad he's my dad.
Yay!
Okay.
I go to the party.
We did it.
I don't know what happened.
I looked at the inventory and now my frames are gone.
I saved your frame.
I activated a glitch apparently.
I go to the party.
Oh, there it is!
What's this?
A photo?
Looks like it's pretty scratched up.
Alright.
What's the last photo?
What the f- an odd photo of two men inside of a strange office.
Is this somewhere inside of Freddy's?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Sorry, dad.
Your f-ing thing triggered my frames.
I don't know what hap- Great.
The bear is out there.
Wait, what?
What do I do then?
Okay, the bear is out there, so...
Okay, guys.
I'm restarting.
I think I should restart the game.
I- What the f-
Okay, windowed?
How the f- do I fix it?
Okay.
Maybe this is it.
No!
What did I do?
What the f- What did I- What did I do?
I looked- I inspected my inventory and it hasn't been the same since.
It hasn't been the same since.
Oh, no.
No.
No!
What?
Oh!
Oh, I fixed it!
I fixed it!
I went to the ball pit!
That's all I had to do.
Get out!
What?
My arm!
Was that the bite of 35?
Did he lose to a f- Dad?
Dad?
Dad, please?
No, not dead.
Please don't be- Dude, he opened his eyes.
What the- What the heck is that thing?
What happened, Oswald?
So, um...
I hid in the ball pit to play a prank on you.
Which I shouldn't have done.
You came to look for me and slipped on the ball- Bro, there's a fucking dead animatronic behind us!
Why are you lying?
Must have hit your head pretty hard when you fell.
I'm sorry, Dad.
I had many more things to get so out of hand.
I accept your apology, Os.
But you're right, you shouldn't have done it.
Bro, like, five days has passed.
Wouldn't, like, the wife think- Like, wouldn't everybody think it's weird?
The wife would be like, Wow, darling.
Last night, you were like- That would be like the- Is it today, Friday?
She'll be like, It's Tuesday.
You and I are beat up pretty good.
Os, what happened?
You don't remember anything?
Well, considering this massive lump on my noggin- No.
Oh.
I was mad at you for being late to pick me up again.
So I decided to hide from you to make you feel as annoyed as I was.
You slipped on the ball and got knocked out.
And five days passed.
We left you on that- We left you in the ball pit for five days.
I'm sorry, Dad.
Oh, Os.
I'm the one who's sorry.
Things haven't been fair to you at all lately.
It's up to me and your mom to keep you happy.
I certainly haven't lived up to my end of the bargain ever since the mill closed.
So...
I think it's time your mom and I talked about moving somewhere better.
For all of us.
Even grandma.
But we can't afford it!
I just moved and it was a lot of money!
Like, how are we gonna afford it?
Who's gonna buy your house?
Nobody wants to live here!
Like- Obstructors, industrial groups- There's a great bubble wrap out there just for her.
Really?
Really.
Now let's get you patched up.
Dad!
By the way- By the way, I think I may be susp- What?
Dude!
What?
How did it fucking get suspended?
Yeah- Jeff?
There's like an- I got an achievement called...
Jeb?
We did it, guys!
We beat the world record!
For three hours!
Three minutes and fourteen seconds!
Oh, for punching the bully!
That's not a suspension!
That's just a detention!
Right?
I never got susp- Oh wait, no, I did.
I got suspended once in my life because I was late too often.
Is there an after credits scene, guys?
Flight, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Imagine being outperforming in bed by seven foot tall.
Electronic, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Guys, I did it, guys!
A world record!
Three hours, three minutes and fourteen seconds!
I love how- I love how there's a speed run timer there!
I think that's fucking hilarious that they put a speed run timer!
I got the two star ending?
How many stars?
How many?
What's the maximum stars you can get?
That's it.
There are two after-credits?
Okay.
Can I skip or do I have to wait until the end?
That was fun though!
I actually really enjoyed this game.
I thought the...
I thought... there's three?
How do you get the three-star?
Yeah, of course I'm gonna submit it.
Whenever it...
Wait, what's the third...
How do you get the third ending?
But you need to do... Oh, fuck no.
No.
I only lacked the three secret...
No, that's fine.
What's the third mini...
What's the third ending?
You play the arcade games?
Okay, yeah, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
I was fine with not playing the arcade games.
Yeah, I enjoyed it a lot!
I thought that was a really fun game.
I usually don't play these types of games, but...
I really did enjoy the gameplay of it.
It was actually scary at points too.
Like, it was very...
I had a lot of anxiety in some areas.
Yeah, unlock new music!
Jeff's Pizza!
Alright.
Is this after credits?
What's going on?
Jeff!
Huh?
That kid better not have gotten hurt in there.
No, Jeff!
Jeff, no!
There's blood!
Jeff!
I'm in solitaire!
Alright.
Well, it looks like Springtrap's gonna run another pizzeria.
Looks like Springtrap is gonna run Jeff's Pizza now.
Now he has to work in the pizzeria.
Well, that was fun though.
I can't believe inspecting items caused my frames to drop.
That has to be an in-game bug!
I'm like, there's no fucking way!
I can't believe inspecting, inspecting the fucking...
It was like, inspect the items, Doki.
What could go wrong?
And then it dropped to like 30 frames.
And then it fixed itself after we get into a cutscene.
And so, I'm like, why me?
Why is it always me?
I fucking bump into every gnome bug in any game I play.
It's actually Cree.
Like, it's a talent at this point.
It's a goddamn talent.
Oh my god, but that was really fun.
I definitely had a lot of fun with that game.
And um, I definitely enjoyed it a lot for sure.
It's definitely like a game that I normally don't play, but definitely had a great time playing it.
Um...
And I really did enjoy the gameplay a lot.
I get why people were saying like, oh yeah, this game was like really good for a FNAF game.
Because I don't know about you guys, but like the some of...
Not like... I heard the security breach is alright, but it's like buggy as hell too.
But like a lot of FNAF games are like very hit or miss.
But this one was pretty enjoyable.
Yeah, I really liked the story building.
I can't believe we couldn't find VTuber kid.
I have no way to fuck... God damn it!
God damn it!
And his Oh-She-kissed kept streaming, so I kept missing him!
Oh my God!
Cass, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you.
Um, it took you three hours to clear this game instead of three nights.
Your top five for sure.
Exactly!
Exactly guys!
It didn't take me five nights and five days to beat this.
Um.
But thank you for the superchat Cass.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe am I right?
Like please, I want to look super cool in front of my chat that they'll let me in.
I hope!
I'll be like, please, I just...
Yeah, I just wanna look super cool!
It's cool in front of my chat.
Yeah, definitely a lot of fun.
I'm glad to be officially back.
No more delays, no more fucking disappearing because I have to move or everything.
I'm like one month behind on work, by the way.
I have so much stuff to catch up on.
But now I can finally catch up on everything because I'm sort of fully set up now.
I'm a new place.
I'm super happy.
I'm really, really happy.
Yeah, I'm one month behind.
So much shit was happening while I was dealing with this.
But it's okay now.
It's okay.
Everything is fine now.
But yes, sound guy, if you're still here, you gotta message me about what kind of...
I'm not gonna... guys, I'm not gonna keep the fucking plushies swoon around my room, guys.
No matter... it's not convenient at all.
I don't want my plushies to get dirty.
I don't want it to just surround the corners.
That's what I actually need.
I actually need, like, these... those foam thingies to, like, absorb the sound.
But it's not as...
For those who are like, what the fuck is she talking about?
This is like... this was what we were... because we were, like, super echoey.
This was our solution to, like, the mega echo.
I'll show you guys for those who are new here.
This was our solution to the mega echo.
Like...
This was... this was our solution.
We need the plushies to absorb the sound through.
And it worked.
I just threw plushies on the floor until they worked.
Until, like, it got less echoey.
So I need to...
Tomorrow...
It was solid.
I hate... I hate the glass door because I hate that he can just...
Dad's just out there looking at me.
It's so fucking weird.
I'm gonna get, like, blinds.
I'm gonna get blinds so he can't look inside.
Anyway, I'm gonna head off now.
I gotta make my schedule for this week.
So... but thank you everybody for coming.
Thank you for all the super chats and all the memberships.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.